[Musique]
lyon
on
mais
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'espère que vous allez bien on compte
un star en général c'est que pour des
vidéos rigolotes des vidéos inspirante
mais là je m'en vais vous parler notre
perso c'est que j'ai décidé de me mettre
à la tordue voilà je vais donc fumer des
pétards et parce qu'il semblerait qu'en
france quand tu es sous l'effet de la
drogue tu ne vas pas en prison le juge
même pas tu peux voler tu peux pas
qu'une bon tu peux roué de coups une
vieille dame
j'ai pu lui casser mise à jour mais le
morceau il ajouté par dessus est d'être
éteinte cette juive et tu ne m'as pas
être jugé donc c'est génial quoi j'ai
commencé à faire des trucs comme ça à
quoi j'ai alors je suis persona sur nous
mêmes bijoux par contre je perds mettre
le masque et puis quand on dira pourquoi
vous mettez pas le masque jpeg gif mois
plus tard j'ai pas de discernement
écoutez fois juge et insulter les gens
dans la rue je peux mettre à la fenêtre
quand la police viendra j'aime et ce que
j'ai fait ma guitare vous pouvez pas
juger
donc on est dans un pays
[Musique]
on peut tuer après avoir roué de coups
et traiter de sale juive une femme est
juste parce qu on a fumé ou ont pris des
drogues avant on n'est pas usé par
contre lors du discernement quant au
rôle quand on frappe à sa porte
la frapper et quand on la passe par
dessus bord donc je comprends plus rien
je vous promets je comprends plus rien
et j'ai un but remonte en fait j'ai un
peu honte
voilà
dans le problème si je suis très
hypocrite et donc je sais pas si je suis
capable je m'appelais tard c'est quoi ce
[ __ ] c'est quoi ce délire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah bah oui
quand on annonce le redis je fais
pendant déchets nucléaires construits
tout ça parce qu'ils s'aiment à paris au
printemps
chérie
m
ans
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
oh
au monde
[Musique]
millions
on
[Musique]
comment
il
[Musique]
non
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
pourquoi
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
ans
non
au moment
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
les sénateurs
c'est bien français
demande quelles nouvelles lois ont dit
soit sur quels usages qui comme ça ne
puisse plus servir à toulon discernement
s'appelle loi ça râle mont lozère qui
n'a pas pu remporter son ancêtre
l'international hommage il a sa mort
tous qu'il n'y ait plus jamais d'autres
salles est tout petit prix auquel ils
avancent ok vive la france
pour que vive la france pour qu'ils
vivent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
m
pour
[Musique]
à 15 heures 30 du matin un individu
s'introduit chez une de ses voisines
une femme de 65 ans ancienne directrice
de crèche la roue de coups et là des
funes malgré ses pleurs et ses
hurlements
l'appartement est maculé de sang cette
femme s'appelait sarah et demi elle
était juive antisémite
passons
[Musique]
il est quatre fronts et donc
irresponsable avec plus de vingt
condamnations et une trentaine de mains
courantes déposées contre lui par le
passé
eh bien il n'a jamais déclaré des
responsables du score on peut devenir
fou contre roye bien des experts pour ça
en plus il a très bien joué il faut et
quand tu es fou tu peut réciter des
sourates du coran juste après pourquoi
pas et quand il ya d'ar gueule tu comme
un massacre comme celui là tu peux
arriver repris en même temps c'est pas
un peu raciste à la barre
[Musique]
en plus vous êtes actuellement ce sont
les autres lui raciste qui bloquait donc
postulat de départ est leader en plus il
affirme un pétard dans cette
circonstance aggravante
quand tu fan excès de vitesse où ni
quand ils massacrent nba avant
évidemment au nez aux assises au
tribunal de police
non
comme il est dingue et drogué il n'aura
pas aux assises oui un drogué mais je
peux trouver du cannabis
elle habille ses pattes avant que
d'autres la prennent habitués comme lui
fumée ne provoque une crise de demos on
s'en fout j'ai dit mon base alors quand
tu dis mon véhicule fumant ça passera
jamais il n'a jamais vu un psy lors de
toutes ces condamnations
il a tenu des propos tout à fait
raisonnable devant les policiers lors de
son arrestation et crises de démence né
le mur que pendant qu'au bout d'un
moment aussi prolifique
la liste outils bon si je comprends bien
il est totalement sain d'esprit il veut
voir si tu me dises juive est tout un
coût des traitements c'est un massacre
c'est bien ça une fois qu'il a massacré
il le redevient sain d'esprit la balance
par la fenêtre pour faire croire à un
suicide
et puis il faut prier ces personnes
exactement incroyable pouvoir le gras
toutes ces tortures cette barbarie
mais la justice française ne pourra pas
walesa des policiers présents sur place
ne sont pas intervenus
ils se sont ils si les astres sont pas
eux qui nous sont laurent bras le sait
ça va toi j
[Musique]
suffirait-il de fumer un joint et de
patent dans la folie pour déclarer
responsable
nous demandons à penser afin que la
lumière soit faite
nous demandons justice afin que sarah à
l'ennemi ne meurt pas une seconde fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
elle s'appelait sarah avec 60
médecin à la retraite s'occupait des
enfants mais son voisin salafistes en
avait décidé autrement
par une nuit d'avril alors qu'elle
dormait le voisin jambes en le balcon
des diarra fracture à la fenêtre et le
visage de ça comme ça
si sa vie
comptez pas
comme sens
comme si la vie n'est compté par la
suite de cette histoire est encore
glaciales l'assassin bien connue des
prisons des centrales a déclaré font pas
la juger les responsables
sa vie ne comptait pas comme ça comme si
la vie nous conter parle d'un jugement
dit un arrêt inédit qui devrait la faire
ça va aller mais on le désire antijuifs
la faute au cannabis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
oh non
dérive de notre france j'ai mal au coeur
j'ai mal au coeur de la france mais où
vas tu m'as france combien de couleuvres
doit-on encore à gérer pour qu'enfin la
taille de notre vente prête à exploser
inquiète quand prendra tu conscience de
cela tu nous perd tu nous perd
inexorablement
tunisair son retour nous y allons sans
détour vers ce grand départ
non seulement car tu nous y pousse à
souci pour les juifs qui toujours
français espagnol italien allemand hors
du marché
changer de route parfois en direction de
la terre promise parfois vers d'autres
horizons petite ville dotée juifs et tu
ne vois pas que c'était mort agit de
perdre à cheikh france par pantois
montre nous que nous avions raison de
croire en toi et hanté père montre nous
que nous avons notre place encore malgré
tout entre nous sur france que nous
sommes des enfants et même titre que les
autres que nous protège que tu là et sur
nous que nous comptons sur toi
notre chère france pour sarah pour ilan
pour myriam cau milliard pour tes
enfants morts pour que le mot justice
est un sens pour que l'eau france est
encore un sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le meurtrier de sara lee mines ne sera
pas jugé malgré le caractère antisémite
de ce crime le président veut un
changement de la loi pour que la prise
de stupéfiants n'entraîne pas cette
irresponsabilité pénale
est ce que ça veut dire gaboriau natale
qu'on va juger les fous dans tous les
cas ceux qui se font pas fait pour des
fous est ce que ça veut dire c'est que
la décision qui a été rendue par la cour
de cassation elle dit le droit mais que
le droit ce qu'est ce que le sens de
cette décision ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui le droit permet qu'une
bouffée délirante comme on dit lié à la
consommation de stupéfiants entraîne une
irresponsabilité pénale c'est pas
possible
la drogue ça doit pas être un permis de
tuer et donc effectivement il faut
changer la loi puisque la loi ne
convient pas que traverse le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas eu un procès ça donne ce
sentiment qu'a prise de stupéfiant c'est
un terme il aimait bien sûr que si
finalement vous commettez un crime
odieux à traire a pris des stupéfiants
et qu'on vous dit parce que vous n'étiez
pas tout à fait vous même parce que vous
avez pris des stupéfiants
vous ne serez pas jugés c'est totalement
inacceptable pour les français et cette
affaire elle provoque légitimement une
émotion extrêmement forte chez tous les
français et donc il faut changer la loi
et président de la république a demandé
au garde des sceaux de faire des
propositions en ce sens il ya une
émotion très forte chez tous les
français je le dis cette affaire peut
nous permettre de faire évoluer notre
droit pour que cette situation ne puisse
pas se reproduire et qui est cette une
irresponsabilité pour quelqu'un qui de
fait est allé tuer une femme parce
qu'elle était juive
ça sera évidemment un progrès
ce matin j'ai honte j'ai honte j'ai
honte que la justice de notre pays
puissent agir de cette façon parce que
au fond qu'est ce que demande et la
famille elle ne demandait pas à
condamner l'assassin elle demandé un
procès bonjour à tous je sais ce que
vous allez bien je suis en plein
tournage et je profite d'une pause pour
vous réveiller cette petite vidéo je
voulais vous remercier du fond du coeur
quand j'ai posté mon cri de colère je
sais pas comment on appelle ça et
quelques jours j'aurais jamais imaginé
que cette vidéo furet le tour du monde
j'ai reçu des appels de new york
d'afrique du sud d'amérique du sud
d'israël
tout le monde m'a envoyé des messages il
faut aussi et j'ai pas pu répondre à
tout le monde on peut dire merci
mais vous savez c'est pas arthur
l'animateur qui a donné son opinion qui
a cassé ce petit clip colère c'est
jacques essebag le père de famille et ça
allait me aurait pu être ma mère ma
soeur ma voisine mon animateurs de ma
cousine et donc c'est c'est plutôt le
citoyen qui a parlé qui a travaillé avec
son cuir peut-être et c'était à refaire
nous concerne tous voilà donc moi je
suis pas quelqu'un qui fait de la
politique je suis pas quelqu'un qui
donne mon avis souvent dit mais pour une
fois j'ai envie de vous dire voilà
mobilisons-nous dimanche et une manif
pour que ça ne se reproduise plus cette
manif ce troquet 0 à 14 heures il n'y a
pas besoin d'études pour venir parce que
la prochaine sera l'ennemi et sera
peut-être catholique musulmane ou même à
t il juste besoin d'avoir des coeurs est
simple le pays qu'on aime
alors on a aussi le droit de défendre
nos idées d'opinion et puis et puis dire
non à cette injustice
voilà je compte sur vous on se retrouve
dimanche à 14 heures place du trophée
d'or
[Applaudissements]
voilà mal de colère et d'incompréhension
après la confirmation de
l'irresponsabilité pénale du meurtrier
de sarah limite c'est que ça génère
juive tu es en 2017 à paris encore cher
bonsoir vous êtes le grand rabbin de
france merci d'être avec nous en direct
soir et wathier fars news pour vous
c'est un scandale judiciaire
cela fait manifestement quelque chose
qui ne correspond pas à la vocation de
la justice qui doit être rendue au nom
du peuple français et bien au delà de la
côte est juive
évidemment il ya une incompréhension
c'est à dire que personne n'accepte ce
que les juges ont bondi à savoir que
quelqu'un qui se met lui-même en état
des responsabilités n'est pas considéré
responsable alors que la même personne
qui conduit en état d'ébriété ou en état
d'inconscience à cause de drogue
on considère que c'est un élément
aggravant à ce qu'il a fait là on
considère que c'est l'exonère de toute
responsabilité
c'est inadmissible parce que ce n'est
pas du tout la remise en cause
je veux le dire parce que j'ai entendu
un leader
deco l'originaire dire que c'est honteux
que nous osions demandé à ce qu'on est
des fous on n'a jamais demandé ce qu'on
fout mais j'ai demandé dans l'article
dans la tribune pour laquelle faisait
allusion au figaro qu'il y ait un procès
la famille a droit à un procès la
victime un droit pour c'est la société a
droit à un procès pour établir les faits
on maudit par exemple reprenant
l'argumentation qui excelle ceux qui
veulent exonérés de toute responsabilité
on nous dit qu'il est une bouffée
délirante allemand ponctuelles ok donc
moi ce que je demande c'est que le
procès puisse établir les faits avant de
savoir quelles hambourg elle fréquente
et comment ils se comportaient sur les
réseaux sociaux
qu'est ce qu'il disait est ce que oui ou
non la une des pulsions antisémite
permanente ce qui semble être le cas
donc moi je ne sais pas autre chose que
ce que dirait le pont c'est donc
j'attends que un procès soient établies
soit fait soit mené si à la fin on dit
il était irresponsable à sont là en tout
cas le conseil aurait établi une vérité
judiciaire
on est privé de ça nous sommes spoliés
de cela je vous le redis la famille la
victime ta société
si la société n'est pas capable de dire
s'il s'amuse pas à moi de le style si ce
n'est plus rendue au nom du peuple
français et donc le sentiment qu'il faut
absolument
si on met ce qui provoque le cas que le
mali sera jugé en droit qui est bien
changeant de droit c'est ce que je
propose dans la tribune que le
gouvernement le présent à zurich propose
un amendement dans la loi qui justement
en ce moment 20 commencer à être débattu
au parlement sur la proximité des
citoyens avec leur justice
eh bien nous avons besoin l'ensemble
soit cette française de comprendre
décisions prises par les magistrats non
je n'accepte pas l'idée que quelqu'un
qui se met lui-même en est à 10
responsabilités soient exonérés de toute
responsabilité je ne veux pas remettre
en cause ce principe qui ne savent qu'on
ne juge pas les fous mais entre juger
quelqu'un qui n'est pas sa raison et
j'ai eu quelqu'un qui se met lui-même en
état de perdre sa raison et une grande
différence que n'importe qui permettrait
de lire que le bon sens permet de
comprendre en quelques instants
manifestement c'était pas la vision des
magistrats de la cour de cassation j'en
suis j'en suis désolé quand à cette
somme de proverbes qui dure ne conteste
pas la chose jugée
quand la chose est mal jugé on peut la
contester demandez à zola qui écrit son
j'accuse grâce à lui l'honneur de la
france a été sauvée
le service jeunesse est beau gentil
puisqu'il vient de se passer quelque
chose dans le pays qui est extrêmement
grave honteux et que ça concerne tout le
monde
chacun d'entre nous est quelque chose à
espérer que toutes les personnes qui
passeront devant cette vidéo l'art
posteront et fera en sorte que cette
histoire prendra de l'ampleur sera
entendu et qu'on puisse avoir gain de
cause parce que c'est honteux ce qui se
passe actuellement dans le pays
c'est honteux indigne de notre pays
indigne de notre histoire est vraiment
c'est salir notre pays que de laisser
cette histoire passé comme ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cet homme ne sera pas
jugé par la justice française
parce que nos politiques et la justice
de nos pays considèrent que cet homme
avait consommé du cannabis avant de
commettre cet acte et que donc une
enquête discernement donc il n'est pas
juge abl
c'est honteux c'est honteux venant d'un
pays comme le nôtre
venant d'un pays comme le nôtre avec
notre histoire de laisser passer ce
genre de choses
vous savez pourquoi dois je rappeler que
cette femme était de confession juive
parce que aujourd'hui c'est un message
sorte qu'on envoie à tous les détraqués
pas des fous les détraqués les gens
conscients qu'ils font du mal parce
qu'il faut arrêter de se cacher derrière
oui il est fou non quand tu rentres chez
quelqu'un que tu sais où cette personne
habite parce que tu connaissais cette
personne il la connaissait que tu
rentres que tu insultes de sale juive
que tu as tu as battu le midi et tu
apportes tu achètes par dessus le
troisième étage au dessus de bâle dont
tu es conscient de ce que tu fais tu es
juste avant conscient d'être un monstre
le message qu'on envoie à tous les
pédophiles de notre pays c'est une et
rejoint avant de violer un enfant et de
tuez vous serez acquitté c'est ça le
message qu'on envoie aux gens dans notre
pays
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui à main qui
veut braquer une banque il a juste
assumer seuls 6 des terres et on lui
dira ah ouais mais non mais il manque de
discernement
au même moment à marseille un homme a
jeté son chien par dessus la fenêtre et
il a pris un autre prison moi
personnellement je l'aurais mis plus et
pendant ce temps que cet homme là ne
sera pas jugé c'est honteux c'est une
justice incohérente et nous on va tous
montrer qu'on veut de la cohérence
un jugement cohérent et une solution
cohérente et juste
cet homme-là qui a tué sarah beeny n'a
jamais eu de problèmes psychiatriques
n'a jamais suivi aucun traitement
pendant son acte il criait allah ouakbar
aujourd'hui on vit un mois saint pour
les musulmans et la grande partie si ce
n'est la quasi totalité de la communauté
musulmane condamne fermement cet acte
parce qu'il ne fait pas partie de cette
communauté parc dans notre communauté
musulmane
on ne tue pas aux noms du rire quand y
tue un être qui tu l'obtiens
parce que issa l'équipe est donc cet
arme n'était pas parti de la paix et
c'est parti d'un terrain et il n'est pas
il est condamnable et toutes les
personnes qui vivaient dans cette vidéo
il vous le verrez dans n'importe quelle
confession juive musulmane bouddhiste
chrétienne at et les homosexuels et
hétérosexuels on s'en moque
aujourd'hui on doit tous se dresser
comme un seul homme comme la république
française parce que liberté égalité
fraternité c'est nous c'est le peuple
on doit tous dire stop ce n'est pas
normal donc la justice de notre pays
doit prendre ses responsabilités
revenir sur cette décision ça aurait pu
être votre mère vous vos enfants
le président de la république le
ministre de la justice et l'entièreté du
gouvernement ils doivent tous prendre
leurs responsabilités et faire condamner
cet homme au nom du peuple français
c'est comme s'ils ont craché au visage
de tous notre pays notre pays c'est l'un
des plus beaux du monde ou d'un arc en
ciel culturel
tu peux trouver des mois des blancs tu
peux trouver toutes sortes détenus et
aujourd'hui on en a ras-le-bol de voir
des gens être tués au travail décès être
salie parce qu'ils sont soit disant
différents la différence vient de loin
de celui qui vole à regarder pour faire
en sorte que soient au courant que nous
ne sommes pas d'accord que nous voulons
un jugement que nous voulons que cette
personne soit jugé comme n'importe quel
tueur de notre pays que cette personne
soit condamné pour ses actes et qu'ils
ne soient pas dehors et que demain et ne
tue pas quelqu'un d'autre
après avoir fumé un joint c'est honteux
c'est un des mots je vous envoie tout
mon amour fait un geste simple décision
mais déplorable parce que si cet homme
d'état
c'est pour notre avenir et c'est pas
juste un petit peu trop juste donc il
faut qu'il soit jugé
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle alexandre arcady je suis
scénariste réalisateur et producteur de
cinéma en janvier 2020 j'ai eu l'honneur
d'accompagner le président de la
république manuel macro à jérusalem à
l'occasion du 75e anniversaire dé
libération d'auschwitz
[Applaudissements]
tous les racismes prolifèrent toutes les
divisions se propage que nul ne pense en
sortir gagnant
[Musique]
en parallèle à cette commémoration
une dizaine de membres de la délégation
s'est rendue au cimetière de guivat
shaoul à jérusalem
dix des onze victimes assassinées parce
que juif dans notre pays sont enterrés
dans ce cimetière en tournant mon film
24 jours la vérité sur la mort d'ilan
halimi
je garderai toujours en mémoire les mots
prononcés par sa maman
au moment où elle a décidé de transférer
son corps pour l'enterrer à jérusalem si
je fais ça c'est parce que je ne veux
pas que les assassins de mon fils puisse
venir un jour cracher sur sa tombe sur
chaque tome nous avons allumé une bougie
et déposer un petit caillou en souvenir
de notre passage
quel terrible épreuve alors que je
demandais à mon ami richard berry de
déclamer l'émouvante plaidoirie de
maître ouaknine melki prononcé lors du
procès de l'hyper cacher
duhamel mi 24 ans jonathan sander 30 ans
gabriel sander trois ans arie sengler
six ans myriam ans et des coûts huit ans
il aura une graine 20 ans philippe braem
45 ans pense qu'on soit michel saad à 64
ans laura va tab 21 ans elle me sarah
halimi 65 ans mireille knoll 85 francs
[Musique]
il est 9 heures
je marche entre les tombes ici le dire
de guivat shaoul à jérusalem
on a commencé à faire finalement le tour
des tombes
la première tombe que nous avons visités
que c'était l'atome dylan il devint vite
on m'en fait les unes après les autres
et de marché et en même temps qu'on
marche et je réalisais l'époque je
faisais qui menait d'une vie à l'autre
et puis finalement d'une morale autre
que ce soit les enfants de l'école ozar
hatorah on que ce soit ça halimi la plus
âgée toutes ces vies un moment donné de
citoyens français se sont arrêtés en
france frappé la folie antisémite
j'allume une bougie sur chacune d'entre
elles je suis pas seul
je suis aux côtés du frère de sarah
halimi et des jeunes tentent la petite
myriam monsonego ce matin froid de
janvier 2020 nous sommes une toute
petite dizaine à nous recueillir sur
toutes ces tombes de citoyens pourtant
bien français ici à jérusalem
ilan halimi en 2006 sa vie a basculé
une bande de barbares sans foi ni loi
l'a kidnappé séquestré torturé et affamé
il a été le premier d'une longue liste
de victimes qui endeuillèrent c'est vrai
que ilan a été le premier c'était une
alerte qui n'a pas été prise
suffisamment au sérieux
je repense toujours à ce que chaque
bande de salopards qui au prix le jeune
pilote et l'ont torturé au loup disait
ne dit pas trop vous allez faire ce
qu'on appelle un effet de répliques
si on en parle les gens vous vouloir
faire la même chose parce qu'il était
juif et parce que pour ce que les juifs
vont tous l'argent et que l'argent ne
pouvait être donnée à ces bons tout seul
par là c'est un assassinat
fondée sur tous les préjugés anti
et je me suis mis à la place de sa main
ce serait pour moi ilian c'était mon
fils j'ai pensé j'ai pensé
la venue vivre j'ai vu aussi ô combien
c'était compliqué terrible de faire
entendre qui vous va
[Musique]
manque quelque chose de nos fonds d'un
drame mais qui portait le jermuk de
l'antisémitisme en 2006 quand je prends
la responsabilité du consistoire g
anne-france l'époque il y aura la bonté
la primaire
qu'on n'imaginait pas qu'on rentrait
dans une phase où les meurtres
antisémite allait se suivre et se
succéder combien d'entre vous se sont
souciés de nos enfants que l'on envoyait
dans des écoles transformées en bon
coeur on l'a vu après effectivement des
autres meurtres les autres crimes
cette montée d'actes absolument ignobles
à toulouse et montauban le la ferme est
rare assassiner des enfants fait pire
des choses inimaginables 19 mars 2012
après le tout vent et l'assassinât des
soldats français
lille je ne nommerai pas a décidé de
continuer sa croisade meurtrières ont
choisi sans une école juive de toulouse
nantes ou coûteux d'un coup et on est
tous très peur quand on était tous
chocques ce monstre est l'incarnation de
toutes ces idées nauséabondes et
véhiculé par des pseudos imams des
intellectuels et des journalistes
haineux à l'égard d'israël après les
meurtres de l'écolo de sarah tu auras de
toulouse ont pensé à la fois qu'il
aurait un sursaut collectif de
l'ensemble de la société pour dénoncer
l'antisémitisme ou rejoindre la place du
trocadéro
après les assassinats de l'école au
sahara tu auras du professeur des
enfants c'est kévé ils ont l'eau que les
juifs et c'est pas moi kennedy c'est une
amie fans de préfet qui m'envoie un
texto qui me dit je suis dans la manif
raie géante
il n'y a que des juifs je veux répondre
vous êtes là tiens d'ailleurs
combien d'entre eux jouent dans cette
salle sont descendus dans la rue pour
les enfants de l'école ozar hatorah tous
combien d'entre vous ont su que nous les
avocats
nous sommes sortis sous les crachats
d'une foule venue soutenir dieudonné qui
se sentaient un soir charlie climat ni
quand j'ai décidé de m'attaquer que la
fin de l'année 2013 à dieudonné je
sentais qu'il y avait un soutien elle
soutien populaire à dieudonné
le geste des partisans de la liberté
d'expression je rappelle qu'il organise
et des spectacles où il faisait monter
sur scène faurisson le négationniste de
la shoah mais cela montre encore une
fois l'étendue du mal de cet
antisémitisme populaire et puis il y à
une hyper cacher
[Musique]
9 janvier 2015 comme chaque vendredi des
français mais par le dîner familial et
intime shabbat
il lui non plus je ne donnerai pas son
nom voulait lui aussi tué du juif il se
prenait pour le héros d' un djihad
sanguinaire et ans se dit et puis et
puis et puis ça se répète
la france est en guerre contre le
terrorisme
le djihadisme et l'islamisme on avait
été plusieurs fois à une guerre mais
dans une guerre il faut utiliser les
arts de la guerre la france est attaquée
par le terrorisme djihadiste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je suis
oh
[Musique]
et
je vais vous dire combien j'ai apprécié
l'action qui glisse alors s inscrire un
nouveau en particulier du calendrier
puisque au moment où toutes les sections
nous devons un élément essentiel pour ce
dossier qui confondent avec impatience
de fabrique qui l expertise
psychiatrique
et cet été nous l'attendions avec
beaucoup d'angoissé prenez une craignant
que puisqu'elle compte us par une
abolition peint d'une abolition la
responsabilité et l'abolition du
discernement
finalement nous n'avons pas une
évolution du discernement ce qui obligea
un grand choix de couleurs un procès
mais aussi
merci à une altération du discernement
qui a été déterminé par les cellules et
des chercheurs
ça veut dire qu'il y aura un procès de
rap française est-ce que vous roulons
maintenant c'est que ce procès ne soit
pas le procès d'un homme qui l'avait sa
soeur nicky sont également le procès de
l'entv teese qui puis dans leur copie et
pour cela il nous faut il est important
c'est pour ça que vous faites
aujourd'hui est important et c'est on
sait qu'il faut continuer
il faut continuer continuer parce que
nous sommes au fond je vais
indispensable et laura fort le péroné
lors rappelons le permet le rapport de
l'ethical écrire que je veux que je peux
pas vous dire depuis que vendredi
fermement que le caractère aggravant ou
d'antisémitisme soit reconnu dans cet
acte ignoble mais il permet également
que la préméditation folie parce que
s'il était prémédité nous sommes
à saint cyr on est prudent le joueur
pour lui dans l'assassinât et
l'assassinât ouvre la voie à la ferté
cnit et et non pas au grand temps qu'ils
sont déterminés par le talonneur qu'on
continue à rester mobilisés
il faut laisser la justice travailler
dans la sérénité de ne pas travailler
sous la pression je rencontre le juge a
aujourd'hui 500 euros le rapport qui
ajoute qu'elle attendait et dans les
jours qui viennent
doit se déterminer et j'espère j'espère
parfois on va être payé que le caractère
aggravant de cet acte
le baiia aggravante d'antisémitisme qui
aura commis dans cette date
et tout comme je vous l'aï dit complète
il profite d'un instant ça le profiter
aussi de l'enseigné qui veulent tous pu
rentrer au pays
voilà c'est les quelques rouges
je remercie merci 30 pour notre
mobilisation
merci pour mobilisation difficile avec
un temps qui disent ils mais josé plat
et cette importance et je crois qu'il
pourra continuer à respectivement 10 et
nous attendons la création la décision
mesdames messieurs bonjour c'est
merveilleux de voir une foule pareille
on n'a vraiment pas de mots mais c'est
pas moi qui vous le dirait je vais juste
demandé aux élus qui sont juste devant
moi sur le pari d'aller sur la droite
le pont en libye s'il vous plais petit à
petit ça va prendre un peu de temps pour
qu'on puisse faire place sur le banc
s'il veut parler de sécurité peut nous
aider ton qu'on puisse commencer à
donner la parole
allez-y
quand
cette erreur
ok est ce qu'il ya en mettant un scène
qui parlait sur wii si vous pouvez aller
sur le côté gauche à quelqu'un qui fait
un petit malaise
m
lire
s'il vous plaît je vous demande de faire
rapidement d'en faire la place
rapidement rapidement sur la droite s'il
vous plaît on doit démarrer et on peut
pas attendre de la place de la place
s'il vous plaît si le service de
sécurité peut vous aiguiller on y va on
y va on y va
à l'avenir que la brise d'un produit
quel qu'il soit puisse excuser un tel
crime que la consommation de cannabis ou
à l'origine de bouffées délirantes aiguë
c'est une évidence et en tant que
médecin il met bien sûr impossible de
critiquer mes confrères roxy 4 mais même
quand on est addict rien rien ne peut
justifier un tel crime
et cela dépasse bien sûr largement le
cas dramatique de sarah halimi la loi
doit changer ces criminels ne sont pas
sous ils doivent être jugés vous faire
part de mon émotion devant ce déni de
justice qui fera que l'a65 sara lee de
répondre à ce crime antisémite
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir le témoignage
de son frère sur mon plateau williams
qui nous a tous mis une claque
il ya un niveau juste il a eu un
comportement qui a fait que toutes les
personnes qui étaient sur le plateau se
sont dit ça aurait pu arriver à ma mère
et ma grand-mère à ma tante nous a fait
comprendre conscience du du drame qui
s'est joué et de ce deuxième drame qui
est en train de se jouer puisque la
salle sainte sara devra pas répondre
devant la justice de ses actes alors ya
une loi qui est en cours d'écriture
actuellement pour que la consommation de
psychotropes ne puisse plus jamais donc
des douanes et les criminels et on
espère j'espère on espère tous que cette
loi portera le nom de sara lee
aujourd'hui on est tous
j'ai envie de dire impuissant devant
cette injustice on se met tous à la
place de la famille de sarah lui et on
est tous de la famille de sarah aligné
aujourd'hui si on fait rien les
prochaines sahara elles seront encore
nos confessions juives bien de
confession musulmane bouddhiste
chrétienne aux autres et c'est vrai que
ça peut arriver à nous tous à un membre
de notre famille alors je vais vous dire
lorsqu'on tue des juifs
lorsqu'on tue par antisémitisme racisme
homophobie
le danger c'est qu'il est là et qui nous
menace tous et aujourd'hui franchement
bravo à vous tous d'être venus aussi
nombreux et je vous dis on espère qu'il
n'y aura plus de cas comme celui de
saint halimi et je tiens encore à saluer
le courage de sa famille et de son frère
william pour qui j'ai un respect immense
et une très grande admiration
merci
je mènerai se cache pas inter je ne
pouvais pas le terme vu l'ignominie que
je ressens l'ignominie je ne trouve même
pas les mots dans le sens où c'est
tellement incroyable ce qu'on est en
train de vivre
sûr que j'entends en fait c'est la voix
de sa radio j'entends la voix de son âme
qui semble me dire qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui se passe quand mon
pays la france
un peu abandonné 1 ce point là a pu jugé
irresponsable la personne qui
responsable de mes torture mais brûlures
de mon défenestration
comment est ce possible est-ce qu'on ait
atteint parole le virus de de l'oubli de
la folie comment on peut réparer une
chose comme ça je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas c'est très important que l'on
cultive l'espoir que l'on cultive la
force de notre pays qui pour le coup on
a vraiment manqué vraiment certaine
cécité psychologique s'est emparé de
cette machine judiciaire la route
oui j'ai honte sincèrement je suis pour
les uns mais j'ai vraiment pour toi une
richesse
[Applaudissements]
comprenne qui pourra
salut les filles
j'y suis avec vous pour pourquoi tester
cette loi qui exclut bien sûr la
responsabilité de trop et le meurtre de
ce pont sarah halimi c'est un programme
donc des bons jours à sa famille dont
qui suit les tout cas où je vous
soutiennent sans justice prado
république bonjour c'est laurie cholewa
je suis là comme vous tous aujourd'hui
pour témoigner mon soutien à la famille
de ce rallye me mais aussi en tant que
citoyenne française parce que demain
sarah halimi ça peut être ma mère ma
voisine une cousine une tante une amie
est très important de se mobiliser pour
stopper les injustices peu importe la
communauté à laquelle nous appartenons
merci à tous les manifestants d'être là
et évidemment aujourd'hui plus que
jamais toutes mes pensées vont à la
famille de sarah ni ils sont témoins
parlent ils vous pour rendre hommage à
sarah halimi et pour déplorer une fois
de plus la bêtise l'ignorance les les
superstitions moyen-âgeuse qui engendre
la violence ou violences
irrationnel je crois qu'il est temps il
est même urgent que se débarrasser de
tout ça et de penser à notre avenir et à
l'avenir de nos enfants
cette affaire de tous nous unir tous
enchantés importe c'est pas une histoire
dé tunis pas une histoire de religion
c'est une histoire d'êtres humains on ne
peut pas laisser un être humain
défénestré une dame et laisser ça
passait pas dans notre pays pas en
france compte sur vous je compte sur
vous votre solidarité sur votre
mobilisation
on doit tous se mobiliser et faire
comprendre que non on n'acceptera pas ça
et on laissera pas sa passe est tous
ensemble pour l'honneur de sara lee mme
dedieu islamistes je répète ça halimi a
été assassiné par un fou de dieu
islamistes qu'antisémite est gênant
c'est juste une vérité une évidence qui
aurait mérité - de procédure et plus de
bon sens et peut-être donné tu aies
refusé un jugement à sarah et mais je
plains ceux qui se refusait à 7 h pour
des exemples qui me paraissent scabreuse
tu tâche difficile srp noble surtout
indispensable pour que notre société
reste debout pour que notre démocratie
notre république nous loire est debout
pour que la france ne soit pas livré à
la pareille à l'obscurantisme à la
violence et la bêtise avec ce permis de
tuer
voilà
merci de m'avoir écouté oui aujourd'hui
je suis complètement révolté indigné
catastrophé par la décision de justice
de la cour de cassation d'interdire le
procès contre le pensionnaire de sa
ligne madame halimi qui a été violentée
assassinés parce que juive
ce pensionnaire la peau aujourd'hui
sortir en toute impunité c'est révoltant
c'est inacceptable encore une fois il
faut se remobiliser tous a exigé la loi
alors il faut changer la loi parce
qu'elle est injuste c'est le tous ces
lieux tout ici pascal légitimus soit en
direct live
ce petit message pour vous signifier que
malheureusement je ne pouvais pas être
des vôtres pour les raisons
professionnelles mais évidemment et
sincèrement je suis de tout coeur avec
vous alors comment peut-on reprocher à
quelqu'un ce qu'il n'a pas choisi d'être
on ne choisit pas d'être arabes juifs
noirs aveugle handicapés italien
portugais sont en pays des droits de
l'homme
évidemment les droits de la femme naïve
la parité est encore de la justice et du
racisme
ok du boulot donc nous allons retrousser
nos manches et aller au charbon
comptez sur moi bonjour je voudrais
d'abord m'excuser de ne pas pouvoir être
là avec vous qu'est ce que je peux dire
en si peu de temps sur une vidéo depuis
quelques années un million de questions
de son réponse la dernière en date étant
comment des hommes et des femmes peuvent
vendre leur âme et conscience aux rendre
cette justice là bon et je voudrais
évidemment témoigner toute ma solidarité
à madame attal devenu halimi à toute la
famille à taille l'attend
entre les halles et me voilà à bientôt
c'est bon et je vous demande
d'accueillir maintenant jonathan béart
entrepreneurs citoyen initiateurs écorne
co organisateur de ce rassemblement
tout d'abord je voudrais vous remercier
je suis obligé de passer par cette phase
mais je vous demande de faire attention
au maski aux gestes barrières s'il vous
plaît j'aimerais commencer c'est le
rassemblement par un moment de silence
pour la policière stéphanie qui a été
poignardé vendredi dernier et je vous
demande parce qu on m s'il vous plaît le
drapeau français en berne marco tous
ensemble un moment de silence s'il vous
plaît je suis dans le silence le plus
absolu
les amis ce rassemblement est déjà une
immense victoire le fait que nous soyons
aussi nombreux sur cette place réunis
avaient tous les drapeaux et une immense
victoire du rassemblement est à l'image
de la libye qui était une fan du village
tu ne faisait pas de différence entre
toutes les croyances
entre toutes les cultures il ya plus de
30 rassemblement dans le monde entier
aux états unis en italie à londres en
france en israël
les amis nous ne sommes pas seuls dans
ce combat
ce rassemblement est née de la
sidération
il est né de la colère quand on a pris
connaissance de ce jugement qui n'a pas
lieu d'être dans le pays des droits de
l'homme qu'est la france
mais cette colère fait notre devoir d
citoyen de la transformer en quelque
chose de constructif en quelque chose
qui fasse avancer notre pays
nous sommes le pays des droits de
l'homme nous nous devons de le faire
avancer nous nous devons de construire
ensemble quelles que soient nos
croyances quelles que soient nos
cultures
nous sommes aujourd'hui toutes réunies
pour cela nous devons mener une action
pérenne
nous devons influencer positivement
locaux citoyen leur montrer que le vivre
ensemble
ce n'est pas qu'une parole vaines ça
existe et on le voit ici aujourd'hui
mais nous devons aussi nettoyer cette
tâche qui est sur notre drapeau que
représente la sphère sara lee me nous
devons la nettoyer ensemble on ne peut
pas se voiler la face
sarah libye a été tué parce qu'elle
était juive parce qu'il ya une culture
de l'antisémitisme mais il n'ya pas que
ça et on le voit ressortir sur les
réseaux sociaux
il y a une culture de la violence il ya
une culture de la haine
il ya une culture de l'excusé ce n'est
pas de ma faute
ce n'est pas moi je suis fou j'ai pas
tout mon discernement mais qu'est ce
qu'on veut nous faire croire
s'il ya une odeur nauséabonde qui se
dégage de tout ça et cette odeur a tué
sarah elle a tué les policiers battu
beaucoup de monde car halimi a été
victime j'étais ni parce qu'on préfère
appeler des terroristes des fous des
déséquilibrés ou on préfère dire qu'il y
avait eu un policier du discernement
est-ce que nous pouvons croire un temps
aujourd'hui jusqu'où ils croient quand
il l'a tuée il a depuis j'ai tué le
sheitan parce qu'elle était juive mais
demain qui sera leur prochain chez tag
est ce que ce sera une fille qui porte
des vêtements un peu trop court à leur
goût est ce que ce sera quelqu'un qui
boit un verre en terrasse avec ses
collègues
est ce que ce sera un presse dans son
église animal un couple gay
l'histoire a déjà parlé tout ça a
commencé avec sébastien selam
il ya eu un halimi il ya eu dix ou douze
ils y arrivent montauban il y a eu
charlie il ya eu
l'hyper cacher il ya eu une mireille
bien entendu il y avait fallu elle pâtit
il ya eu le bataclan il y a eu 10
il ya eu beaucoup d'autres et plus
récemment rambouillet on ne peut pas
laisser faire on ne peut pas laisser
l'obscurantisme nous vouloir occuper le
terrain les habits nous sommes ici pour
amener la lumière une lubie à citoyenne
et lumière où nous sommes réunis
2 quel droit ces gens là se revendique
t-il appartenir aux valeurs de l'islam
il ne porte aucune carrière de l'islam
il ce qui représente les valeurs sont
ceux qui sont là aujourd'hui avec lou
ce n'est qu'ensemble que nous pouvons
réussir ce n'est pas le combat d'une
communauté ou d'une autre ou d'une autre
nous sommes tous réunis pour ça allait
me aujourd'hui nous sommes tous réunis
pour ça va halimi mais si la police ne
peut nous défendre et si la police ne
peut se défendre si la justice ne peut
être rendue
mais vers quoi allons-nous vers quel
futur allons nous les problèmes se
règlent ici nous avons deux objectifs à
cette manifestation
la première c'est que la loi visant à ce
que la consommation de psychotropes ne
puisse plus servir d' excuses par faire
corps à une abolition du discernement
nous ne sommes pas seuls aujourd'hui
dans ce combat nous sommes tous
rassemblés et vous allez voir des élus
des magistrats des philosophes des
artistes et beaucoup d'autres tous
réunis pour la même cause
qu'est ce qu'il penserait et ce qu'il
pensait qu'on a leicester et ce qu'il
pensait qu'on allait laisser passer ça
seul un fait quatre ans que nous nous
battons pour cette cause depuis 2010 est
à faire du bruit à moto a défilé passe
de la république
mais aujourd'hui ce rassemblement est la
preuve que nous tous nous portons les
mêmes valeurs que nous avons été touchés
dans nos valeurs les plus profondes avec
ce justice avec ce jugement que nous
tous nous sommes au fond tous les lem
[Musique]
ensemble
nous avons le pouvoir de faire bouger
les choses
ensemble nous pouvons faire bouger le
monde entier il en est la preuve
ça bouge de partout aujourd'hui nous
avons déjà fait bouger le monde beaucoup
de choses bougent
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous unis pour
une grande cause nous sommes tous unis
pour sa halimi et pour tous ceux qui ont
précédé si justice n'a pas été rendue
pour sara lee mis la justice sera rendue
craint centrale est bien avec cette loi
[Applaudissements]
tout ça pour ça
c'est notre devoir de citoyen français
pour que vive la france
nous devons être unis et je sais je sais
nous savons tous que nous pouvons
compter sur votre soutien indéfectible
quel que soit votre culture quelles que
soient vos croyances nous ne formons
qu'un seul peuple ce peuple c'est le
peuple français je vous demande s'il
vous plaît d'accueillir maître szpiner
maire du xvième arrondissement
m m merci de nous accueillir dans votre
arrondissement
merci nous accueillir chez vous en tant
que maire du xvième arrondissement sur
ce parvis des droits de l'homme
je suis heureux de contempler cette
place du trocadéro plein demande
cette manifestation est un succès elle
dément ce qu'ils disaient que ce crime
notez est ce que la communauté juive se
grime intéresse et interpelle toute
notre nation parce que dans la
république quand on en vient à tuer
quelqu'un parce qu'il est né autrement
ce n'est plus la république et
aujourd'hui je suis heureux de ce
sursaut de voir des hommes et des femmes
d'horizons politiques différents de
confessions différentes comprendre qu'il
est nécessaire que nous soyons unis pour
sauvegarder l'idéal républicain
l'idéal républicain c'est la fraternité
c'est le regard bienveillant que nous
portons les uns sur les autres c'est le
respect de l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes
c'est le fait d'accepter que quelqu'un
puisse être différent et ce tir celui
qui à thury sarah halimi c'est celui qui
refuse tout cela c'est ce qui dans notre
pays mène un combat contre nos valeurs
et ce n'est qu'en étant unique comme
vous l'êtes aujourd'hui que nous
arriverons à faire front je remercie
tous ceux qui sont venus ici tous ceux
qui vont parler avec leur différence
avec leur histoire avec leur expérience
pour que demain ceux qui s'attaquent à
la république comprenne que nous sommes
déterminés à la défendre
merci d'être venus ce sursaut
aujourd'hui ne doit pas de s'arrêter
il doit être le prélude de lendemain de
combats et je suis sûr que fort de votre
enthousiasme nous y arriverons
je vous remercie pour la famille ça va
aller me pour la justice et pour la
république
[Applaudissements]
ok vous pouvez pas savoir ce que ça fait
de ce côté là ici à la place où je suis
de vous voir si nombreux
si nombreux aujourd'hui sur cette place
sur cette page consacrée aux droits de
l'homme
je ne sais pas comment vous remercier au
nom de la famille de sarah au nom de
tous les avocats de l'organisation juive
européenne qui porte ce combat depuis
quatre ans maintenant
au nom également de jonathan béhé et
franck tapiro et cyrielle cohen qui
n'ont pas démérité pendant ces quatre
années également un immense merci à vous
tous vous tous pour votre présence et je
veux maintenant vous dire quelques mots
vous tous qui êtes sur cette place vous
savez vous savez que sarah halimi était
une citoyenne française qui toute sa vie
toute sa vie je vous dis bien toute sa
vie avait respecté le droit la justice
de son pays la france en se comportant
de manière exemplaire comme une
citoyenne française torturé défénestré
choisi par son assassin parce que juive
elle n'a pas été protégé dans un premier
temps par notre police elle n'a ensuite
pas été défendu par notre justice
son droit en droit à la justice le droit
de sa famille à avoir des questions des
réponses à toutes ces questions qui se
sont posées pendant ces quatre ans
depuis cette terrible nuit du 4 avril
ce droit à la justice lui a été ôtée par
nos magistrats nos magistrats français
que nous côtoyons tous les jours dans
les prétoires
nos magistrats français qui rendent la
justice au nom du peuple français
vous m
que nous sommes que sera limité est-ce
que vous avez toutes vos réponses à
toutes vos questions dans cette affaire
est ce que vous vous reconnaissez dans
cette décision de justice qui a été
rendue par la cour de cassation
est ce que le président de la république
lui-même emmanuel macron se reconnaît
dans cette décision de justice de la
cour de cassation
est ce que le garder sans qui a appelé
ce matin changer la loi se reconnaît
dans cette décision de justice
une nouvelle loi changera-t-elle quelque
chose pour sarah notre demande
notre demande à nous les avocats qui
combattons au quotidien pour sa main
halimi depuis quatre ans notre demander
la révision de ce procès la charge est
la grosse tête de sa valise du ranger
tous les juges de rendre enfin une
justice digne une justice âge une
justice intelligente une justice humaine
à vous monsieur le président de la
république monsieur le garde des sceaux
de tout mettre en oeuvre pour que cela
soit enfin possible à nous à nous tous
présents ici nombreux de continuer le
combat pour que notre voix soit enfin
entendue et qu'elles portent loin
qu'elles portent fort et qu'elle nous
permette enfin d'obtenir justice pour
sarah et demi ensemble dans les arbres
du droit de converger pour nous
tous ensemble une loi plus fort pour les
jeux de tir pour aligner pour la famille
de sarah lee je vous demande maintenant
de faire un tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour la iakoutie porte ce combat qui
nous a confié la défense de ses intérêts
monsieur will i am attal qui se bat
depuis quatre ans sans répit nuit et
jour depuis quatre ans pour que justice
soit rendue donateurs il ya matin
cette journée j'avais qui sait c'est
sarah halimi ma soeur elle est présente
parmi nous permet vous mercredi dernier
il ya dix jours un coup de tonnerre
un coup de massue la cour de cassation
confirmait l'irresponsabilité pénale de
l'assassin mais seulement maintenant
quelques heures plus tard l'espoir a
commencé à revenir
et dès le lendemain
l'espoir grandit c'est une clameur venue
du chef montait montait sarah aller mais
avait intercédé auprès de la chaîne
auprès du bon dieu on ne pouvait pas il
ne pouvait pas abandonner
chara mais sert cette clameur
elle monte monte monte espoir est revenu
et les ce point c'est vous c'est vous
ici maintenant
à cette heure ci dans le monde on dit
justice en anglais andy justice en
hollandais ont dit justice en italien
andy justice en mai breux
on hésite on dit justice en québécois
andy justice en anglais américain
un miracle le mirage de saint remy et
votre présence ici est d'une extrême
extrême importance dans la nuit du 4
avril
l'obscurantisme a vaincu a décru
des valeurs du nano blech extraordinaire
l'obscurantisme de mes chèques obili
traoré
à détruire il a détruit la noblesse
d'âme il a détruit la grandeur il a
détruit
l'honnêteté il a détruit
l'amour du prochain vous savez il a fait
un master ce qu'un frère ne peut
supporter de voir
il a fait souffrir ma soeur comme c'est
pas possible
mais il a fait une première un
communiquera au rire fait une première
erreur
après la robe massacrés à coups de poing
a coûté un coup de téléphone dans
l'appartement
ça ne lui a pas suffi il l'a traînée
trenet tirer plein de sang il y avait
lui aussi pied plein de sang et le tir
et jusqu'au balco pourquoi tu le fais ça
pourrait que finir ma soeur dans
l'appartement
pourquoi il l'a tirée jusqu'au balcon
peut-être malheureusement c'était pour
montrer montrer vos voisins qui le
regardaient ce que l'on faisait à sarah
la jules ce qu'il voulait c'était
expulsé de son immeuble jetée aux yeux
de ses voisins
farah lajoie
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être qu'il
aura perdu je les dis je les dis je le
répète j'ai rencontré cette semaine un
des témoins clé témoin clé du massacre
polytraumatisé sa vie est en partie
détruite
décrite par ce qu'il a vu détruit par la
violence
l'extrême cruauté d'un individu qui
n'avait plus rien d'humain
à ce moment là ou plutôt qui compte ici
elle est deir es ma soeur qui ne la
considérait pas comme un être humain je
m'excuse de dire à messieurs les
magistrats que non non il n'a pas
d'abord crié j'ai tué le sheitan encore
une imprécision
quand il a fini de tuer ma soeur il a
crié j'ai tué le secteur du quartier ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses
c'est une première indication
des fois pendant qu'il assassine et ma
soeur devant ces vingt témoins devant
ces neuf policiers qui cherchaient qui
cherchait à trouver où était le problème
ou été l'assassinât
il a traité ma soeur il a insulté ma
soeur dans sa condition de femme je
n'ose répéter ce qu'il a dit il criait
salle pays dont ils criaient san l op 1
ce n'était pas un démon qui tu es
c'était une femme c'était ma soeur je
n'ose imaginer les coups qu'ils recèlent
cammas y recevait d'une violence inouïe
inouïe elle a reçu des centaines de
coups sur le visage elle a reçu une
centaine de coups sur le corps à la fin
ce n'était plus une femme qui criaient
c'était
un bébé est à trèbes c'est un animal dit
gilles michel l'erreur de monsieur
commune et traoré s'est d'abord voulu
montrer ce qu'il faisait à sarah la
juive et c'est la première erreur je
communiquerai est maintenant bien sûr
dès que je relis dès que je revis ces
moments je ne peux pas ne pas continuer
le combat
je ne peux pas laisser cet individu sans
jugement je dis pas plus deuxième erreur
la deuxième erreur de monsieur
communiquera oreilles ça s'est produit à
la cour d'appel ne savions rien rien de
ce qui se passait rien les informations
étaient au futur un cour d'appel nous
découvrons au suco billy traoré
changement de décor en pleine forme en
pleine possession de ses moyens
un individu comme vous et moi et alors
d'ailleurs les experts le coeur zagouri
excellent
le docteur bensussan légèrement moins
bon confirme qu'en schirm que cet
individu là dans l'état où elle était et
qui vous affirme qu'il a pas de
traitement
il ya un an et demi depuis des mois et
des mois qui n'a pas de soins c'est la
stupéfaction au niveau des experts et
d'ailleurs vous faire une confidence
c'est pas grave le de thurgovie se
retourne vers un deux avocats et il lui
dit nous allons gagner
nous avons gagné quand le docteur
bensussan reconnaît qu'il s'est trompé
dans toutes ses expertises
il s'est trompé dans son diagnostic il a
il avait parlé de maladie mentale grave
de type schizophrénique incurable et en
fait et en fait il reconnaît qu'il s'est
trompé
on pensait à ce moment là qu'on allait
gagner une deuxième chose d'une extrême
importance que dit monsieur connu traoré
il allait depuis trois à six mois
cinq fois par jour à la mosquée sarah
fils omar on l'a découvert et j'ai
demandé à mes avocats
mais pourquoi vous n'est pas exigé de la
juge d'instruction
pourquoi on n'est pas exigé une enquête
à la mosquée salafistes réponse de mes
avocats incroyable parce que on nous
n'avait rien dit on nous avait rien dit
ensuite un scénario le scénario du
marabout on nous annonce qu'il était
marabouté et de mettre mail qui
s'adresse à lui il dit
mais comment s'appelait le marabout
réponse de cobly traoré mais non ce
n'était pas un marabout
c'est un fidèle de la mosquée
toutes ces conclusions tout ce qui a été
dit dans cette cour d'appel qui était
d'une importance crac capitale n'a pas
été pris en compte par les magistrats de
la cour d'appel
ça nous aurait été bien utile est pire
que ça pire que ça malheureusement
la greffière qui avait marqué toute la
journée qui avait écrit toute la journée
ce ce qu'on a pu appeler excusez moi de
vous le dire un mini-procès ou un
simulacre de procès ça n'a jamais pu
nous être tête
transféré à nos avocats et donc on peut
on peut pas s'en servir
tout ce qu'on sait qu'il sait qu'il
irait 54 sonne tout ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il y avait des journalistes
mais on ne peut pas l'utiliser alors oui
deuxième information extrêmement
importante que billy traoré était un
familier de la mosquée salafistes marre
à l'intérieur une information la
dernière née avant l'assassinât de ma
soeur il a été cinq fois la mosquée
c'est le fils thomas et il y à la tesla
10 heures du soir
qu'est ce qu'il faisait à 10 heures du
soir à la mosquée c'est la piste
la troisième erreur de monsieur koné
traoré c'est d'avoir cru que c'était
fini qu'il allait gagner et la 3g meyrin
ge et son compte facebook son compte
facebook
dans son compte facebook première
stupéfaction ne m'a pas il ne se avant
l'assassinât s'était pas sa photo il se
faisait appeler boubacar fofana
stupéfaction
et l'erreur de monsieur kobe traoré
c'est d'avoir ri ouvert en juillet 2020
un nouveau compte facebook à l'hôpital
en soi disant hospitalisations sous
contrainte
et là il a mis sa photo et là il a mis
la photo de ses amis qui viennent le
voir pas 5 par dix en pleine forme
une photo prise dans le parc de
l'hôpital de saint maurice première
coust premières constatations il est en
pleine forme
deuxième constatation ses amis nous
considèrent ni comme un malade ou comme
un assassin
ces mêmes amis ces mêmes amis qui est
qu'on a reconnu qu' quatre jours après
la marche blanche organisée par monsieur
joël mergui écrivait les postes comme
ces deux matches qu'on n'était pas là on
l'adorait tous humains supplice de
chiens
quatre jours après l'assassinât de ma
soeur des postes de cet antisémitisme là
on en a recueilli beaucoup beaucoup 10
points qui sont vos amis je vous dirais
qu'ils vous êtes avons merci julien plan
j'ai perdu
[Applaudissements]
maintenant je vais vous annoncer une
nouvelle avant de passer la parole avec
jonathan baer béart se met en colère les
ports jamais avec mouiller les portes
sous lakers ou et nous avons appris
vendredi une nouvelle d'une extrême
importance
un témoin clé capitale a contacté un
atteint la limite qui est dans la foule
et que j'attends mon neveu ce qui m'a ce
témoin-clé capitale était une est une
puéricultrice qui travaillaient avec ma
soeur et cette pellicule trice nous dit
dans une vidéo et lt monnerat gobbini
traoré et ses deux soeurs depuis des
années traiter sarah halimi de sale
juive je n'ai plus la famille atteint
halimi et moi talent qui déclare ça au
juge et pour lequel on ne le crois pas
nous commençons à voir des témoins il ya
un deuxième témoin et non mais est
extrêmement important
polytraumatisé et qui nous dit quand
j'ai croisé le regard de cobly traoré il
m'a terrorisée
alors oui oui oui cody lee traoré c'est
un salafistes islamistes d'un
antisémitisme virulent dans la station
on est très très loin
on est très très loin de son ex cris de
ceux qui ont écrit les experts
on est très très loin les experts
parlent dans leur rapport d'un préjugé
intention antisémite
on était très loin de ça on est dans un
antisémitisme virulent c'est le même
antisémitisme qui a massacré à la
mireille knoll c'est l'airé menti
sémitisme qui a torturé pendant trois
semaines
ilan halimi je vais avoir l'occasion de
vous raconter d'autres éléments
je passe la parole à jonathan bea avant
que sous pli
[Applaudissements]
to be pour les ménages avait délivré
s'il vous plaît
- droite où est le droit aux et le droit
à beaucoup je vais pas juger
un assassin qui tue froidement qui tue
vêtements comme ça qui a joint et king
aura pas de procès oui le droit où est
le droit ou et ça fait deux fois qu'on a
cassé puis milliers on a le droit de
demander qu'on change la loi
10 de l'eau c'est pas très beau si je
fais ça c'est pas pour toi nous citoyens
juifs ou chrétiens athées aux musulmans
on a le droit d'aimer vraiment une
france qui tous ses enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah d'accord
je rappelle je m'appelle linda et je ne
ferai pas l'affront chaîne sahara je
m'appelle francine je ne serrez pas la
prochaine sahara je m'appelle sophie et
je ne serais pas là prochaine sahara je
m'appelle annie paule et je ne serai pas
à la pochette sahara
je m'appelle hama je ne serai pas ma
prochaine st je m'appelle et les mains
et je ne serai pas à la prochaine star
[Applaudissements]
je ne devrais pas approcher sans merci
mesdames
merci nous appelons maintenant les
présidents de communautés ainsi que les
représentants des autres communautés à
nous rejoindre
monsieur francis khalifa je vous invite
à nous rejoindre
président du crif
mesdames et messieurs le premier
intervenant c'est francis khalifa
faisait partie
[Applaudissements]
mes amis nous ne sommes plus seuls la
france est dans la rue aujourd'hui pour
dire non à cette injustice à ce déni de
justice
ici à paris mais aussi à marseille
toulouse bordeaux montpellier nice lyon
et strasbourg et vous avez entendu mais
je veux et les répéter je veux répéter
le nom de ces victimes juives ses
victimes de l'antisémitisme
sébastien selam ilan halimi youn atteint
darier gabriel semblèrent ni rien
monsonego you avatar bio à rennes cohen
françois michel saad à philly brown
sarah halimi et myriane hall dans cette
trop longue litanie de noms et de
visages de victimes du terrorisme
antisémite
chaque destin est un destin singulier
chaque vie brisée est une injonction aux
souvenirs
chaque homme chaque femme chaque enfant
h et à la vie est un appel à tirer
collectivement les leçons de l'histoire
et pourtant pourtant il y est tu qu'il
est une victime pour laquelle ce travail
de mémoire ne peut se faire c'est sarah
halimi pourtant pourtant sarah halimi a
été torturés massacrés parce qu'elle
était juive pas parce qu'elle se
trouvait sur le chemin du tueur
sarah halimi n'a pas été défenestré
parce qu'elle avait de l'argent non
sarah halimi a été placée sciemment
assassinés parce qu'elle était juive et
pour cette unique raison
sarah halimi a été la victime d'un crime
antisémite pensée planifié et exécuté
dans un reee du est dans un rituel et
une mise en scène islamistes barbare et
sordide sarah halimi est la victime de
cet antisémitisme que la société
française peine à reconnaître et à
nommer elle est la victime expiatoire de
l'antisémitisme islamistes et en
confirmant irresponsabilité pénale de
son assassin la cour de cassation pris
définitivement la famille de sarah
halimi d'un procès indispensable à son
travail de deuil mais aussi elle prive
la france toute entière d'un procès
historique
le procès de l'antisémitisme qui tue
encore aujourd'hui dans notre pays
et alors alors que plus qu'une évidence
il s'agit là d'un véritable cas d'école
pour décrire un meurtre antisémite ce
crime ignoble ne sera pas jugé et dans
un contexte où l'antisémitisme ne
faiblit pas la justice emplois à très
mauvais signal
elle met à bas 20 ans d'efforts et de
combat pour qu'enfin l'on reconnaisse
que les actes et violences que subissent
les français juifs ne sont pas de la
violence ordinaire mais bien
l'expression violente d'un antisémitisme
nouveau c'est une terrible régression
particulièrement inquiétante pour
l'impunité qu'elle conduit comment la
justice de notre pays
peut-être à la fois reconnaître le
caractère antisémite d'un crime et
offrir la punit t à son auteur en
refusant qu'il soit jugé
nous sommes en pleine schizophrénie nous
ne le dirons jamais assez chargera
halimi a et étiers tué deux fois elle
est bien sûr la victime de
l'antisémitisme islamiste du tueur mais
sahar halimi est aussi la victime d'un
déni de justice et d'un naufrage
judiciaire
alors alors pour que son nom soit
inscrit dans la mémoire de notre pays
la nouvelle loi doit porter le nom de
sara lee me c'est une forme d'hommage
qui nous seraient rendus veut demeurera
rendu justice
merci francis méthot équipe on va parler
je les passais la parole maintenant
précédente et consistoire que ce joël
mergui
mais je voudrais d'abord souligner la
présence de son excellence en bas ça
doit quand même se baigner
chers amis je redoutais je redoutais ce
moment je redoutais cette prise de
parole nécessaire pourtant j'ai eu déjà
la responsabilité d' exprimer ce que
vous ressentiez au lendemain de
l'assassinât d'ilan halimi
puis de la tuerie de toulouse denis
payre cacher de sara lee me2me
reine-claude à chaque fois dans la
détresse et la douleur j'ai cherché à
répondre au malaise grandissant des
français juifs à leurs interrogations
légitimes sur notre avenir
j'ai cherché à chaque moment des raisons
d'espérer et de vous rassurer
quand je dis vous je parle des français
juifs et des français non juifs car tout
le monde j'espère enfin compris que nos
sorts sont définitivement lié passe au
fléau islamistes
j'ai dit et répété que temps que l'état
son gouvernement sa police
saint justice nous protéger nous devions
résister et continue à croire et à
construire notre avenir
alors vous la voilà pourquoi je
redoutais ce moment aujourd'hui puis-je
encore dire la même chose
après cette décision de justice qui nous
fragilise
ce signal catastrophique envoyé aux
criminels et au monde entier
je comprends les doutes et les
interrogations et je les partage
je ne sais même plus si j'ai envie de
rassurer ou de crier ma colère oui de
crier votre colère
donc aujourd'hui en pleine guerre contre
l'islamisme
il n'y en a pas de procès pour un
islamiste qui assassine une grand mère
française
[Applaudissements]
parce que l'on ne peut pas juger un
soi-disant fou qui assassine dans mère
juive pas assez fou pour choisir avec
préméditation sa voisine gilles mais
juste assez fou pour échapper à la
justice
le seul procès d'un assassin islamistes
antisémite qui pouvait avoir lieu est
donc interdite vous m'avez souvent
entendu me posez la question à quel
moment de l'histoire sommes nous je peux
répondre malheureusement aujourd'hui
nous sommes un tournant grave
une décision qui fera date une tache
noire dans la confiance et prendre ces
juifs dans notre pays
supporter l'antisémitisme supporter
lundi serait supporté les assassinats
c'était un véritable défi que notre
histoire nous a appris à relever mais
supporter ce déni de justice sur un
assassin islamistes reconnus
antisémistes est impossible je le dis
bien impossible pour le responsable que
je suis pour le juif pour le simple
citoyen pour le médecin
le président a promis une loi et nous
l'en remercions
elle ne pourra cependant être
rétroactive
la maire de paris donnera certainement
un lieu dès que le remercieront
mais
combien de rue
je devrai à béziers et je reprendrai mes
raisons d'espérer que si on nous propose
des moyens effacer cette tache noire sur
notre justice
si on trouve les moyens que l'assassin a
soit jugé un indispensable procès pour
donner l'exemple d'une justice
exemplaire et ne pas devenir un contre
exemple de justice
merci à tous nos amis présents
aujourd'hui dans leur diversité
vous nous rassurer donnez-nous aussi des
raisons d'espérer en partageant l'open
comme aujourd'hui mais a aussi en
encourageant nos projets de vie merci
merci joëlle métrât rien goldbach
président du fonds social juif unifié
chères familles de sarah halimi chers
amis
cela vient d'être dit depuis 2006 la
france a été le théâtre de aux
assassinats antisémites et pas de procès
pour ces assassins de sara lee ni on
assassine a motivé par la haine
antisémite d'un islamisme radical qui
gangrènent la société française aux
assassinats où il a fallu se battre
souvent trop souvent pour que la justice
reconnaisse le caractère antisémite
pourtant flagrant dans la sphère sarah
halimi la juge d'instruction a pendant
longtemps refusé de caunes est de
reconnaître que l'assassinât d'une femme
juive aux cris dans la barre était un
crime antisémite
ce n'est qu'après plusieurs mois de déni
que le crime a été reconnu pour ce qu'il
était de toute évidence un attentat
antisémite n'est pas de procès toutes
les lignes blanches ont été franchies
torture prise d'otage mortels enfants
massacrés dans la cour d'une école et de
douleur d'une femme qu'on roue de coups
qu'on défenestre corps brûlés d'une
autre qui pourra arrêter ce cauchemar
sinon la justice aujourd'hui comme
beaucoup de français qu'ils soient juifs
ou non
je ressens très grand malaise au delà de
l'incompréhension de la déception de
l'amertume
cette décision est un choc oui cet arrêt
sont comme un coup de tonnerre dans un
ciel très sombre
la cour de cassation avait une
application stricte de la loi
on aurait pu espérer qu'elle fasse
autrement vu le contexte et les
conséquences invraisemblable qu'on
prenne sa décision
depuis le début de l'instruction jusqu'à
l'arrêt qui vient d'être rendu cette
affaire provoque un sentiment de perte
de confiance
à tort ou à raison cette décision de la
cour de cassation est ressentie par
beaucoup comme un coup porté aux efforts
des pouvoirs publics depuis tant
d'années dans la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
je suis avocat ce métier je les choisis
parce que j'aime que ce soit rendu
justice
j'aime que les lois soient le garant de
la sécurité de chaque citoyen quel que
soit son genre sa religion
lorsqu'elle ne le sont plus il faut sans
attendre les changer si tel avait été le
cas sans doute qu'aujourd'hui
l'assassin de sara lee pourrait être
jugé alors après la colère qui est
légitime il y à l'espoir
l'histoire c'est vous l'espoir ce sont
les représentants des autres cultes
catholiques chrétiens musulmans athées
agnostiques tous ceux qui nous ont
rejoints aujourd'hui et l'espoir et
l'espoir
ce sont ces propositions de lois venu il
ya bien longtemps du sénat donne il ya
quelques jours de l'assemblée nationale
est venu ce matin du gouvernement à
l'initiative du président de la
république alors oui gardons l'espoir
mais nous sommes le peuple de la mémoire
et de l'espoir
n'oublions jamais ce à aligner ayant
espoir en la nouvelle loi
sarah halimi je vous remercie
on va aborder les dix secondes je la
remercie l'ensemble des associations
celles qui sont sur scène et c'est bio
et dès aujourd'hui la réalisation de
cette merveilleuse et de ce grand
membres à 10 heures rassemblement
fraternel applaudissaient les très forts
bercy bien servi avant mais doit
maintenant accueillir les responsables
des cultes autour du grand rabbin de
france monsieur rahim korcia monsieur
françois verly président de protestants
monseigneur thibault vernis évêques père
christophe lesourd santoni boussemart
président des bouddhistes merci merci à
tous de votre présence
linden viol bouzidi et mamouth iyaz
grande mosquée de paris
monsieur noah mais nous sommes au
président du cfcm
oh non non non non non non s'il vous
plaît merci à tous de votre présence
l'imam chalghoumi thomass maximos pas
fini ce représentant de l'église
orthodoxe et ne se niche est tout bénef
pour l'emploi de paris ils vont mais si
tout ce temps avant
quel bonheur d'avoir sur cette tribune
l'ensemble des religieux comme les
agnostiques comme les laïcs
merci d'être présent à chacun d'entre
vous échappe aux ennemis
après ce témoignage bouleversant que
faire du docteur sara lee
après tous ces témoignages des
responsables d'associations je voudrais
faire ce que le peuple lui a toujours su
faire et donc tous les cultes sont
toujours inspirés la prière qui est une
forme d'action parce qu'elle dit qu'on
n'abandonne jamais et donc je voudrais
avec mes amis de tous les cultes réciter
le psaume 133 qui dit la chose suivante
qu'il est beau et agréable que les
frères résidant ensemble somme ne le
fera en hébreu que mes amis le front en
français une réciteront la prière pour
la république et enfin je ne citerai un
kaddish ménages cas là pour le docteur
sara lee
j'ai vraiment l'autre david healy madoff
ou naim chez de tarim camarades
quel schéma nature et la roche sur et
d'al kanz icahn a renchéri dalpé milette
âme quitte à la ferme en théorie de
l'art et yonne shamsi madonna est très
rare a trahi mme anna olam
[Applaudissements]
quel bonheur quelle douceur pour des
frères d'être ensemble
c'est comme l'huile parfumée sur la tête
d'aaron qui descend jusqu'à sa barque
jusqu'au bord de son vêtement c'est
comme les gouttes de rosée de la
montagne de les rebonds qui descendent
sur la colline sur la colline de sion
les berom
le maire va vers le lieu saint et
remercier le seigneur que le seigneur
vous bénisse
depuis le temple de jérusalem lui qui a
fait le ciel et la terre
éternel maîtres du monde
la providence embrassés sous la terre la
force la puissance t'appartiennent par
toi seul tous élèves et tous affermis
tes de moeurs à tout seigneur bénisse et
protège la république française et le
peuple français amène de la france
heureuse et prospère qu'elle soit forte
et grande à l'union et la concorde
mais la mène vers élan totalitaire qui
préside aux destinées de l'état ils font
régner l'ordre et la justice
amen
que la france puisse d'une paix durable
les français sont rembourrés lieu
milieux dits nation amen quelqu'un
accorde sa protection sa bénédiction à
nos forces de l'ordre et à nos soldats
qui en france et partout dans le monde
défendent la france et ses valeurs
leur courage leur ténacité leur force
morale sont notre honneur
accueil favorable on nous veut que les
parents d'élèves les sentiments ne se
retirera de rentrer aux éternels notre
créateur de libérateur amen et c'est
rising star arguments sekera reine des
matériaux fisheye rap naïf qu'à l'aller
des méchants rahman ajouté mais chacune
de mettre ses doigts mairesse brasse
sarah a time event halimi war adoun est
innée reinhardt et ghanéenne cardinal
zen qui rôde et leur match moyen mais la
variable club
ben mishkin jeunes qui arrivent à vous
chers une norme euro iv rool nice reçoit
tu m'as desquels un train à me masser
les refréner radson benomar amer
bien entendu on rappelle le savez moi je
rappelle toutes les victimes de ces
violences antisémites depuis tant
d'années et c'est pour eux pour toutes
et tous que je dis ma part le caniche
ilya dall vite qu'elle achevait rabat el
maghra siroter un miroir ou des
vêtements pour canet les quatre heures
mais chercher ailleurs nous y sommes et
ron fraser sperme et israël vague à
l'âme humaine qu'arriver mots eux-mêmes
et je me rabats mais barclays à la
mairie mais rien il en restera ensuite
pendant huit romans business ebitda
envie terrible talal jeu mais les coups
de chaleur ou et la moule mais rattachés
retard du bord de mer ce matin de
mirande galmarini romaine
les schémas robert inch'alla aimé savoir
échoue à venir à marie-josée var fois au
bout lance quatre ans fera pas avant 25
ans là nous font la moue israël 3 m
ces chaleurs minimale ou votre mari à
ses chats mais nous colle à moïse rennes
i mohammed et merci nous donner à tous
une grande leçon d'espérance voudront va
produire très forts de votre réseau
certains d'entre vous par exemple alors
vous pouvez vraiment remercier tous les
représentants du culte et en particulier
représentent au culte musulman à qui je
dis ramdane moubarak a fait beaucoup
merci merci encore de votre aisance je
vais demander un ciel cohen de me
rejoindre sur scène
cyrielle les journalistes elle a réalisé
une vidéo
avec les proches des victimes des
attentats cyrielle les très difficile de
se prononcer quant à des journalistes
par devoir de réserve
beaucoup de mes confrères le savent mais
n'est-il pas plus difficile de détourner
le regard
face à l' inaudible et l'indicible
alors j'avais besoin d'agir à ma manière
parce que j'ai enquêté et fait des
reportages sur la sphère sarah halimi en
2017 pour une chaîne de télévision et
donc à la demande de williams attal j'ai
réalisé cette vidéo
coécrite l'habitude des victimes
coécrite avec deborah attal fille de
william attal et réalisé plus tôt montée
par jean luc des aides
pourquoi parce que dans
chez tric il dit il y a comme un essai
ça à mon sens la force de cette vidéo
inédite
il ressentait alors halimi mois
donniacuo luc mois latifa une visite
mois patricia korea - elles servent
aulas qui frise dubreuil que nos fans de
jonathan solaire maman darier et gabriel
sengler dans ce cas fils qui furent que
je meure dylan halimi maman de sébastien
fille la fille de georges wolinski maman
de précisa correa juive juifs freudien
juive juif juif de coeur musulmane mais
avant tout française
nous nous unissons lutter contre le
terrorisme
l'aérodium et l'antisémitisme le moule
rond pour que la france de demain toi tu
aimes france de respect et de tolérance
une france de communion et d'unique et
constance qui vont dire avec fierté
ils vont aborder dans le public crochet
aujourd'hui pour qu'il n'y ait plus
jamais de nouvelles ilan halimi
2 hors droits j'ai peur que je leur
permets de ma carte jambes de sébastien
selam de mieux recul ni de charlie hebdo
de beltrame de clarissa gencives à
toulouse l'auto bonne entente à paris ou
encore de rambouillet et les autres nous
nous joignons aux combats de la semaine
de sanyo et clame d'une seule voix à
notre détermination pour que vive la
liberté
les
moi williams atteint prince à aliso
assassiné le 4 avril 2010 elle réclame
justice ça
[Musique]
il
les otaries
[Applaudissements]
merci maintenant j'appelle ceux qui
store castaner président du groupe
elle rend même à l'assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
révolution s'il vous plaît je vous
demande de ne pas faire de ces bruits
inutiles
nous sommes ensemble et si vous voulez
critiquer ont crié vous avez d'autres
occasions aujourd'hui nous sommes
ensemble voilà nous demandons l'unité
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs en france
aujourd'hui et l'attentât de rambouillet
nous le rappellent cruellement la haine
tu toujours sarah limite était un parent
une amie une voisine
elles étaient pour certains un portrait
un sourire elle était une femme de
confession juive et c'est pour cela
qu'elle n'est plus parmi nous
aujourd'hui sarah halimi a été assassiné
en raison de sa religion
c'était il ya quatre ans et notre colère
est toujours intacte l'antisémitisme est
un venin puissant il prend différentes
formes différents visages et avancent
parfois masqués parfois un visage
découvert et il est toujours violent
personne personne ne peut l'accepter
je dis en tant qu'élu d'une république
laïque indivisible qui doit protéger les
citoyens de toutes les confessions je le
dis en tant qu'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur fier fier d'avoir renforcé
la sécurité de synagogues fier d'avoir
biais sous des groupuscules antisémite
violon et d'avoir aidé à ce que la
nation condamne ceux qui dévoient un
concept et font de l'anti sionisme le
prénom de leur antisémitisme le dit
enfin
et peut-être surtout en tant que citoyen
citoyens qui l'antisémitisme provoque
une réaction épidermique et qui se bat
depuis toujours contre lui
malheureusement et l'assassinât de sarah
halimi nous le rappelle ce combat reste
d'actualité alors nous ne baisserons pas
la garde nous ne renoncerons pas nous ne
cesserons jamais de combattre les
préjugés de combattre les agressions du
quotidien de combattre les paroles les
théories absurde qui mène au pire cela
débute par des préjugés
cela peut se terminer en meurtre quel
citoyen accepterait cela pour ses
proches pour les habitants de notre
nation éducation sécurité justice sont
les trois piliers de la lutte contre
l'ignorance crasse contre la violence
contre le terrorisme
ce sont les piliers de notre état de
droit ces derniers jours justement le
droit a été dit mais nous gardons tous
le sentiment que la justice n'a pas été
rendue
pour qu'une société tiennent debout quel
con 10 et qu'elle s'épanouisse elle doit
avoir une justice intelligible sourds de
passion durs envers les criminels
responsables devant les citoyens
le juge ne peut pas distinguer là où le
législateur ne l'a pas fait
ce doute ce trou noir judiciaire ne peut
perdurer
et c'est justement pourquoi nous allons
changer la loi je le dis clairement
l'irresponsabilité pénale à sa place
dans notre droit
je suis parfaitement opposé à l'idée du
g1 fou les fous les personnes qui ne
contrôlent pas leurs volontés qui n'ont
pas de discernement peuvent être soignés
suivi interner mais ce n'est pas la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
un homme qui a pris de la drogue en
toute conscience et qui a assassiné une
femme parce qu'elles étaient jumeaux
c'est en tant que citoyen et
législateurs que je le dis si un homme
pleinement conscient a causé sa propre
folie
il ne devrait pas être irresponsable il
serait trop facile de se réfugier
derrière les effets des drogues pour
fuir ses responsabilités il serait trop
simple de consommé une drogue est mû par
et nancy mise bien ancrée d'aller tuer
une femme juive sans que la
responsabilité de l'auteur ne puisse
être interrogé le président de la
république exprimée avec force
il nous faut agir l'état actuel du droit
créé des situations humaines auxquelles
il est nécessaire de répondre nous le
ferons avec ordre nous le ferons avec la
justice au coeur est loin des
déclarations à l'emporte-pièce des
spécialistes des solutions toutes faites
on décrit le droit pour lutter contre
l'injustice et la colère peut être un
saint moteur elle ne peut pas quitter la
plume de ceux qui rédigent des principes
qui auront vocation à s'appliquer pour
des destinées à venir mais je vous le
dis on liens étroits avec le garde des
sceaux avec qui j'ai changé hier encore
la majorité va modifier la loi une loi
sur le discernement pénale est en
préparation
il ya la demande du président de la
république nous avons sorti cette loi
sera présenté en conseil des ministres
avant la fin du mois de mai et le
travail parlementaire devra permettre
son vote avant l'épée nous avançons
sereinement et efficacement
avançons avançons ensemble avant son
pour punir les criminels et ne le
présente plus mais exprime une volonté
claire
le cap est fixé et je vous le dis au nom
des députés du groupe que je préside
oh non je pense aussi d'une grande
partie de la représentation nationale
avec le garde des sceaux un travail est
engagé
à beautiran chère amie sarah halimi a
été la victime de l'antisémitisme
peut-être aussi d'un droit incomplet qui
donne ce sentiment d'injustice
nous allons le changer vous pouvez
compter sur moi
vous pouvez compter sur nous notre
détermination à combattre la haine est
plus forte que jamais merci la sienne le
show christophe painset merci de me
rappellerai toujours de notre voyage
nous sommes allés ensemble sur la tombe
de ses douze victimes de l'antisémitisme
en france
merci la cycliste de votre présence
merci à vous les choses amis alors je
vous le savez c'est un moment
particulier et que cet après midi est
organisé mais elle a aussi ses surprises
et des belles surprises
les gens de coeur des gens qui comme
vous comme nous tous avaient envie
d'être là et je vous demande d'applaudir
très fort
nos invités arthur arthur
michel bouchard avancé patrick que
pouvait bien un petit bureau
je pense qu'il avait un message à faire
passer
le 14 mai 1990 j'étais présent à la
manifestation contre la profanation des
tombes du cimetière juif de carpentras
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de monde ce
jour-là
un crime antisémite c'est la cause
aggravante de ce crime mais attention au
piège
attention à ce piège qui enferme cette
chose dans un crime uniquement
antisémite
la prochaine sarah halimi sera peut-être
chrétienne musulmane noir et on sera
aussi dans la rue parce que c'est ça qui
nous définit et c'est ça qui nous
détermine
j'ai lu avec beaucoup de colère les
interventions de magistrats envers
arthur avec beaucoup de condescendance
beaucoup de prétention avec un manque
d'humanité et de compassion de renvoyer
les gens au fait qu'ils ne connaissent
pas les lois ça ne suffit pas on n'a pas
besoin de connaître les lois pour être
en colère pour être outré pour être
scandalisé que dans un pays comme la
france aujourd'hui on ne juge pas un
homme qui a tué de manière préméditée
intentionnel une femme parce qu'elle
était juive parce que l'été femmes
d'ailleurs les féministes aussi on a
besoin de vous aujourd'hui
voilà je suis là pour tout ça je suis en
colère et j'espère que des mesures
seront prises pour que cet homme soit
jugé pour prévenir aussi tout ce qui
viendra je l'espère pas bien entendu
dans les années prochaines
et pour que nos enfants mes deux garçons
ne me reproche jamais de n'avoir rien
fait aujourd'hui je suis là aussi pour
eux regardez vous avez la meilleure
vidéo pour une millions 10 millions de
vu que ma réseaux sociaux moment il est
là en vrai arthur moi je suis là parce
que je suis un homme de coeur merci john
legend prononcé mon nom je crois que
vous connaissez
[Applaudissements]
je suis père de famille et j'ai été
extrêmement choqué par ce qui est arrivé
à sara lee mis sur le cul arrive à ma
mère à ma tante à ma soeur ma voisine à
n'importe qui qu'il soit gilles vous pas
assez scandaleuse qui s'est passé même
si cet acte odieux et antisémites nous a
meurtri n'oublions pas que la justice
est là pour nous citoyens nous sommes
français avant tout et c'est important
qu'elles changent cette justice qu'elle
s'améliore cette loi alors pendant poser
cette manifestation pendant ce grand
rassemblement le garde des sceaux a
annoncé qu'il a changé qu'il est proposé
des mesures au prochain conseil des
ministres et nous en sommes ravis
moi je demanderais juste qu'une seule
chose que pour rendre justice à ça
allait me cette loi porte son nom la loi
sarajevo pour qu'on n'oublie jamais
ça fait plaisir de voir tous aussi en
gros ça fait plaisir de voir tous ces
visages juifs non juifs on s'en fout le
plus important c'est que tous les soyez
tous les citoyens se soient mobilisés et
peut-être qu'elle nous regardent de
là-haut et j'espère que les fier fier de
vous fier de nous tous parce que grâce à
elle les choses je l'espère vont changer
ni pour ne pas se retrouver encore dans
trois ans à la énième manifestation
contre des crimes odieux commis contre
les juifs
voilà je vous aime très fort on est là
sur la mousse sur la plage et vous
l'avez en vidéo aux ballerines la vraie
fausse alerte
[Applaudissements]
hier avant-hier et les jours qui ont
passé j'avais honte de mon pays
j'avais honte de cette décision mais ce
soir surtout aujourd'hui quand je vous
vois quand je vois des noirs des
musulmans des chrétiens des juifs
ensemble réunis là je suis fier lâché
pierre tissier saluant ce mois saint
pour les musulmans que je suis
aujourd'hui j'ai fait et j'ai soif de
justice vers la libye
c'était ma soeur ma tante ma mère
c'était un membre de ma famille et je
m'en moque de sa religion
je m'en moque de sa différence parce que
moi je vois ce qui nous rassemble est
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande au
gouvernement
ces données justice parce que pour une
fois qu'un de ces lâches est encore en
vie il s'est pas suicidé lâchement comme
la plupart de leurs actes
on doit juger
j'ai pas honte de dire que bloche
faisait de moi je vous aime profondément
et que c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai ce
qu'il essaye de nous faire croire qu'on
est tous divisés non la france est
liberté égalité fraternité
et aujourd'hui on l'a prouvé alors que
votre geste ne sert pas à rien que sarah
halimi vivre en chacun d'entre nous
qu'on n'oublie jamais parce que sa race
a signifié le s de solidarité le a deux
amours le r le rassemblement le a encore
une fois d'amour et le hd histoire alors
selon babbitt mes enfants - et
allons-nous territoire justice pour ça
[Applaudissements]
et je nous allons passer la parole à nos
amis nos fidèles
michel boujenah il séjourne à ce récent
arcady à vous
il était trop grand
le temps passe
et à chaque fois ça recommence on m'a
demandé totalement plusieurs fois
pourquoi j'étais là j'ai souvent répondu
que le problème de l'antisémitisme
c'était le problème des antisémites il
c'est vrai il y avait plein d'avenir -
ce matin qui me disaient mais tu vas
aller à la manif ou pas encore une manif
à quoi ça sert
mais quand je vois tout ce qui se passe
depuis tout à l'heure quand je vous vois
vous quand je sens qu'il ya une vraie
émotion et une vraie volonté ford
alors je suis content d'être là
aujourd'hui avec vous après dans
manifestation après tant d'années il
faut toujours être là même si parfois on
peut penser que ça sert à rien il faut
être là il faut montrer qu'on est là il
faut montrer qu'on est vivant il faut
montrer qu'on se laissera pas faire
même si la vérité bien des moments du
petit cul
je vous embrasse tous mais c'est un
cauchemar
écoutez
mais on attend
en prenant la parole devant vous cet
après midi j'ai envie de juste de vous
dire qu'il ya environ 20 ans pour la
première fois j'ai été à auschwitz
l'impensable était devant mes yeux
c'était un moment une douleur extrême
avec cette notion de passer ses
tailleurs et au cours de ce voyage le
grand rabbin de france a pris la parole
et nous a dit quand on est ici sur ce
lieu de mort
on a envie de se taire on a envie de se
recueillir 1000 faux pas il faut parler
et encore parler et encore parlé l année
dernière en janvier dernier à l'occasion
dû voyage du président de la république
en israël nous avons été une poignée à
nous rendre à guy match house et là
c'est devenu comment dire quelque chose
de 2,6 fort de si profond nous
recueillir de tombes en tombent
en partant dylan alinghi ilan halimi
2006 on a tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
on nous a dit ça ira c'est pas grave
c'est juste un épiphénomène
et puis ça continue et toulouse hilbert
cacher
et sarah ligne et aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de penser à cette fin à cette mère à
cette soeur à cette grand mère c'est la
nôtre celle qu'on a connue celle qu'on
connaît et d'imaginer son calvaire cette
nuit-là assassiné comme elle l'a été
avec la police présente et ça aussi il
faudra qu'un jour on nous explique
pourquoi la police était là pendant une
heure de temps à aligner rester leurs
amis dit il et de la cour personne est
intervenu ça aussi il faudrait que me
disent les avocats de l'ong lino de la
famille qu'il y ait une reconstitution
cela aussi ça a été refusé on ne sait
pas ce qui a été dit dans les dents le
téléphone que cet assassin avec la
police en sait rien qu'on ne sait pas
grand chose sauf qu'il a fumé du
cannabis
sauf qu'il n'était pas en état de
discernement mais ce qui exclut ce qui
est clair c'est qu'il n'était pas un
dictateur au cannabis il était surtout
addict à l'antisémitisme
on se souvenir que ce jour là il a il a
quitté la mosquée de la rue jean pierre
timbaud avant d'accomplir ce crime
abject s'est posté tout cela dont il
faut se souvenir et aujourd'hui je vous
le dis franchement en tant que français
en tant que citoyen j'ai honte j'ai
honte parce que la justice s'est passé à
côté d'un procès exemplaire j'ai honte
parce qu'on est en guerre
cette guerre et les terribles est notre
seule arme à nous citoyens de ce pays
c'est la justice la justice qui doit
rendre des comptes
la justice qui nous a condamnés pour
nous protéger et cet homme ne sera
jamais content à le condamner
comment va-t-on être protégé une grande
prière pour sarah halimi merci mes amis
[Applaudissements]
demande d'applaudir vincent dissez
audace moi moi dans les grands parents
maternels ne sont pas revenus des camps
mois dans les hontes 4 ne sont pas
revenus des camps je pense que ce sont
le droit de dire ici que le non jugement
de l'assassin de sarah halimi torturé
roué de coups des sinistrés parce que se
dire qu'avec du mot jugement la justice
s'est déshonoré
celle c'est une blessure une blessure
faite au plomb que vous risquez une
vision faite au peuple français tout
entier qui est un peuple épris de
justice et épris de fraternité c'est une
blessure qui ne se refermera pas de
sitôt comment ces gens qui ont pris
cette décision peu futiles encore dormir
comment peut-il encore se regarder
en face comment il avait à manger salé
part dans les droits de tuer c'est une
des pires erreurs judiciaires de la
france est connue et cette union se
passera jamais oui aujourd'hui ils sont
démunis et nous sommes tous ça va régner
nous sommes tous sa famille et je prie
pour que nous n'ayons pas à connaître de
nouveau cette horreur et ses injustices
pareil merci d'être là je salue et
remercie de faire c'est pas très grave
et qui si leur bourse et dans la salle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le dernier dimanche du mois d'avril
c'est la journée de la mémoire de la
déportation
c'est aujourd'hui
moi je suis juif français qui n'a pas
connu ses grands parents lorsqu'ils ont
été déportés à auschwitz
ça m'a marqué évidemment toute ma vie
j'ai eu la douleur de mes parents qui ne
se sont pas remis de cette trahison est
ce qu'ils ont été déportés étaient
français et sauvian c'est la police
française qui les a emmenées et déporté
à auschwitz et les parents sont plus de
ce monde et je suis heureux qu'ils
soient plus seulement celle qui ne vois
pas à quel point cet antisémitisme qui a
été leur douleur qui a été la mienne est
à nouveau présent aujourd'hui il serait
triste éminemment triste et c'est vrai
qu'on a eu cette douleur par rapport à
l'état français qui a déporté
ces juifs l'état français a reconnu ses
fautes mais aujourd'hui on sent bien on
sait tous que il ya un déni de justice
la preuve dupond moretti a annoncé qu'il
y aurait une autre loi
c'est la preuve que cette loi qui a fait
en sorte que ce monstre ne se voit pas
juger est une mauvaise loi et on doit
accepter cette mauvaise loi
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
c'est impossible parce que tout le monde
sait que c'est pas d' assassin c'est un
monstre et que son ça pouf et délirante
n'est qu'un alibi l'année dernière et
quand nathan avait aussi voulu réunir
beaucoup de monde la république
on n'était pas très nombreux cette année
on est beaucoup plus nombreux et c'est
formidable de voir autant de monde
je suis fier d'être à nouveau là parce
que c'est un combat qui ne finit pas et
comme l' affaire dreyfus il faut
continuer à se battre parce que même
s'il a pris des années et des années et
des années on a réussi à ce moment là à
voir notre édition du 3 c'est vrai que
c'est bien il faut continuer
sa présence à paris pour à dallas talent
et de sud rail était aussi déplacé la
règle dans notre île et vis à vis de
sarah halimi peuple de paris chrétien
musulman agnostique de toutes
confessions et de toutes croyances
je voudrais vous dire que ce qui me
frappe le plus aujourd'hui
lorsque je pense à cette terrible
séquence dont nous ne sommes pas prêts
d'être sorti c'est d'abord son île
une manne it et je ne parle pas
seulement de l'inhumanité du crime
je ne parle pas seulement de ce beau
visage de sarah halimi torturé martyrisé
outragé et défénestré est assassiné je
parle de l'inhumanité
des juges à qui il a fallu des poires
[Applaudissements]
mais le caractère antisémite de ce je
pense à l'inhumanité du droit français
tel qu'il est écrit aujourd'hui la
lettre
moi qui ne permet pas de nommer ce crime
atroce 7 août rac
je pense à l'inhumanité des juges de la
cour de cassation qui comprend clés à la
responsabilité d'avoir une
interprétation restrictive ou généreuse
de la loi ont choisi la solution la plus
restrictive la plus frileuse et la plus
infâme et la plus inhumaine
je pense des charges et à l'humanité de
tant de commentateurs dont la première
réaction a été pour dire qu'il fallait
respecter les décisions de justice une
décision de justice était par définition
sans appel il y avait la face à cette
atroce inhumanité face au corps de
madame halimi martyrisé comme celui de
rabbi akiba sous le sceau de ses sous le
rac haut de ses tortionnaires quelque
chose d'horrible
dans cet appel à l'apaisement que l'on a
senti partout je pense que dans cette
séquence les mots les mots que nous
employons tous les jours ont perdu leur
sens ou sont en train de perdre leur
sens et deviennent inhumain
responsabilités culpabilités bouffées
délirantes distinction entre la bouffe
est venue de ceux ci et la bouffe est
venue de cela mais qu'est ce que cela
veut dire
ça ne veut plus rien dire
quand les beaux quand les mots ne veut
rien dire cela veut dire un pas de plus
tragique vers l'inhumanité
ça veut dire que le sol se dérobe sous
nos pas à tous qui que nous soyons la
flo meurtre de madame halimi a fait
c'était cet étrange le destin le destin
de cette petite dame modeste qui honore
les dieux avec ça sa gentille et p elles
ce sont mortes a provoqué un immense
désordre dans la république française un
vacillement le sol se dérobe sous ses
pas face à cela
face à cela il y as me semble-t-il
mes chers amis deux choses à faire
d'abord sahara à la limite c'est ce
visage très beau que j'ai en face de moi
et que j'avais dit et que j'ai à
l'instant sur mon coeur
or vert de mon veston et que je suis
fier d'avoir ici je porte peu de
médaille je suis fier de porter cette
médaille de cette dame qui ressemble à
mes tantes cette dame qui ressemble au
dam de ma femme il est de la famille de
quelques-unes et de quelques-uns d'entre
vous il faut lui conserver son visage
son nom et il faut honorer ce nom et ce
visage comme il
besoin aujourd'hui et comme j'espère
pour quiberon delecray mais il faut
aussi mais il faut aussi que le paysage
de ça allait me devienne un symbole
c'est souvent le destin des juifs ce qui
leur arrive et parfois le signal de
quelque chose de plus redoutable encore
qui se passe dans des sociétés à partir
d'aujourd'hui il y a
en france une affaire halimi est temps
que cette affaire alibi ne sera pas
pensé je pense que la france ira mal
il ya deux manières de penser ce qui
doit devenir à partir d'aujourd'hui la
sphère halimi d'abord la loi en effet
qu'a annoncé le ministre aujourd'hui et
dont j'ai proposé la semaine dernière
c'est la moindre des choses pas qu'elle
soit l'appendice d'une loi générale pour
rendre la justice plus proche des
français n'ont cette loi j'ai proposé
j'ai souhaité j'ai fait savoir qu'elle
devait porter le nom de madame halimi
c'est une grande avancée
révolutionnaire français et premier
républicain que de 2,2 dans certains cas
le nom d'une personne illustres ou dont
le destin a été suffisamment dramatique
pour que cette loi soit marqué de son
sceau
son nom et puis je pense que le procès
de monsieur traoré doit être révisée
nucléaire c'est officiel et été épuisés
il ya des cas dans l'histoire du dernier
siècle français pas nombreux il y faut
des conditions particulières et ce très
stricte mais il ya eu des cas de
révision de procès
lorsqu'un élément nouveau appareil qui
n'a pas été prise en compte par les
instructions précédentes qui est de
nature à faire face il y ait ou changer
la conscience des juges
alors il est arrivés des dizaines de
fois au 20e siècle
au terme d'un processus complexe mais
absolument que didier que la loi soit
révisée
[Applaudissements]
il appel à témoins
il faut que l'on en sache davantage sur
les motivations de l'homme qui sortira
probablement bien avant les 20 ans de
peine de sûreté de son hôpital
psychiatrique
il faut que tous les éléments possibles
soient rassemblés il faut que autour de
la famille de sarah halimi autour d'eux
les organismes des organisateurs de
cette belle manifestation d'aujourd'hui
un comité pour la révision du procès de
traoré sous et se met au travail
alimi
contrairement à un groupe français à qui
la plus élémentaire justice a été dénié
elle n'est pas elle à l'île du diable
elle est dans le sainte abraham
mais là où elle est si un jour ce procès
venait à être révisées si un jour même
de manière posthume la justice venait à
être dit
alors il me semble que madame halimi là
où elle se trouve serait heureuse
n'oublions pas que tourne à penser
le jour commence toujours avec le soir
nous y sommes
merci merci j'avais matin monsieur luc
ferry
[Applaudissements]
très bref mes amis j'ai juste 3 3
réflexion à vous proposer
oups
le premier séjour et tordre le cou à un
mensonge que j'entends répéter y compris
par des gens aimables
ils sont pas forcément des mauvais
bougre ils disent que c'est dommage mais
les magistrats ne pouvait pas rendre un
autre jugement que celui qu'ils ont
rendus parce que c'est le droit positif
français c'est faux il pouvait
parfaitement rendre à notre jugement
pour trois raisons qui n'ont pas été
habitués n'était pas d'accord entre lui
n'était pas unanime
deuxièmement les magistrats sont
souverains en toute hypothèse ils sont
obligés de suivre l'avis et les idioties
troisième temps les magistrats se sont
lancés dans une orgie d'une
argumentation que je trouve parfaitement
absurde l'écouté bien elle consistait à
dire et j'ai regardé les choses de près
que l'assassin de sa halimi ne pouvait
pas savoir qu'il allait développer une
bouffée délirante
parce que consommateurs réguliers de
cannabis il n'en avait jamais développé
auparavant
attendez ce serait plus raide rire si ce
n'était pas tragique quand vous fumé un
pétard pour vous avez là une bouteille
de whisky
vous savez bien que ça peut être tiré le
jugement c'est précisément pour ça pour
le fun et c'est précisément pour ça que
c'est interdit par la loi
[Applaudissements]
tiens contexte et niais ce contexte est
absurde c'est plus calme sur c'est
indigne
toutes les enquêtes montrent que depuis
les années 2000 et notamment une enquête
qui a été menée par la fondation pour
l'innovation politique montre que les
crimes antisémites de sang les meurtres
les violences physiques ne sont plus
majoritairement le fait de l'extrême
droite
pas même le fait de l'islamo gauchisme
de l'extrême gauche bien que
malheureusement la montée de
l'antisémitisme soit présente dans ce
courant mais pratiquement tous les
crimes de sang toutes les violences
physiques sont le fait du
fondamentaliste islamique ne pas le dire
c'est simplement être complice cette
réalité
ces camps et contrairement à ce que je
lis parfois sur la toile je ne suis pas
juif
je vais vous faire un aveu personne
n'est part ça je ne suis pas la seule
lueur d'espoir dans cette affaire est
atroce vraiment atroce je vais pas
revenir sur les faits on les a tous en
tête la seule petite lueur d'espoir
c'est que justement aujourd'hui n'est
pas seulement ici contrairement à ce
qu'a dit bêtement à nos écologistes dont
je tairai le nom par charité c'est pas
simplement la communauté juive qui est
meurtri quand tu es juif est assassiné
parce qu'il est juif et l'humanité
entière qui est atteinte
en tout cas je revendique le droit
d'être aussi mauvais que les membres de
la communauté juive qui sont ici
plaisant et qui fort heureusement pas
les seuls
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis pas venu vous dire le
droit c'est pas mon métier fallait-il ou
non jugé le fou je ne sais pas je suis
pas juriste
j'ai mon idée là dessus je laisse à
d'autres le soin d'y répondre certains
l'ont déjà fait non ce que je sais en
revanche est ce que je suis venu vous
dire est ce que je veux partager avec
vous et de tout mon coeur c'est que ce
n'est pas parce que l'homme n'ait pas
jugé qu il n'y a pas eu de crime et les
gens qui se servent de la cour de
cassation pour dire qu'on peut
maintenant passer à autre chose
sont des [ __ ] en fait je suis venu
vous dire trois choses très rapidement
très rapidement
la première c'est que l'antisémitisme
n'est pas soluble dans la folie si fou
soit il
l'assassin de madame halimi est d'abord
antisémites et savait pas la drogue qui
rendit sémites ni la bouffée délirante
non ce qui rend antisémites avant de le
dire ce qui rend 6 mx et l'environnement
la sas a un vécu dans un environnement
où on lui a appris à détester les juifs
a en fait des diables et a considéré que
leur disparition et est un bienfait et
n'ignoraient rien de la religion de sa
victime
c'était sa voisine la propre soeur de
l'assassin l'avait accueilli un jour en
crachant par terre aux cris de sales
juifs alors peut-être que l'assassin est
fou quand vous tuer des juifs vous êtes
fou peut-être de l'assassin est fou mais
alors sa folie n'est que le reflet de la
haine où il a grandi
l'islamisme et l'antisémitisme
frénétique qui gangrènent certains lieux
de la république sont les assassins de
madame halimi et cela les prétoires
on en compte
la deuxième chose que je voulais vous
dire c'est que il est insupportable et
épuisant d'entendre dire à longueur de
journée que les tueurs de femmes juives
sont d'abord vous que les agresseurs de
juifs dans la rue sont d'abord des et
été déséquilibré ou que lecture de
charlie hebdo ont d'abord eu une enfance
difficile
dire ça c'est esquiver la réalité dans
ce qu'elle a de pire dire ça c'est
esquiver la haine dire ça c'est
pratiquer le tennis et le déni du lui
aussi alors il faut remettre les choses
en ordre
quand on tue nés juifs on est à bord
antisémites et après on est fou
et enfin et on pas contrairement à ce
que disent certains élus ce crime n'est
pas seulement la sphère de la communauté
juive mais bien la sphère de la
communauté nationale et la communauté
nationale n'est pas une addition de
chapelles plus ou moins concernés selon
la catastrophe
ce crime n'est pas seulement le drame
des juifs c'est le drame de la
république c'est la tragédie de la
france sartre termine ses réflexions sur
la question juive par cette phrase qu'on
est nombreux à connaître écouter ça
passe un français ne sera en sécurité
tant qu'un juif en france et dans le
monde entier pourra craindre pour sa vie
[Applaudissements]
nous avons le grand plaisir d'accueillir
ce le président de la région ile de
france
monsieur xavier bertrand
[Applaudissements]
je suis ici pour honorer la mémoire de
sarah halimi je pensais à son martyr à
sa famille et je veux d'ailleurs
témoigner ma solidarité à la famille de
sarah halimi à son frère que nous avons
entendu tout à l'heure et à vue exprimés
m'appelle ce crime ne doit jamais être
oublié
je suis d'ici en citoyen aussi dire une
chose très ça se droguer c'est bel et
bien un acte volontaire
la vérité c'est que cette bouffée
délirante qui aurait conduit le
meurtrier à commettre l'irréparable
il se l'est infligée à lui même par des
pratiques il a choisi lui-même d'adopter
ce sentiment insupportable que la
consommation de stupéfiants ou d'alcool
crédibilité je n'accepte pas et vous ne
l'acceptez pas comment accepter alors
l'absence de procès comment ne pas
réagir face à ce que nous vivons
ressentons comme un déni de justice
il est un principe c'est que nous devons
respecter les décisions de justice de la
cour de cassation mais nous avons un
droit celui de ne pas comprendre et
celui de vouloir changer la loi et le
faire au plus vite
c'est une exigence vis-à-vis de sarah
halimi
c'est une exigence pour la république
française alors cet article 122 1 doit
être modifié
je tiens aussi à vous le dire si le
gouvernement décide dans les jours dans
les semaines qui viennent de présenter
un tel texte et ne sera pas question de
majorité ou d'opposition
il ne sera question que de la france et
je soutiendrai l'adoption d'un tel texte
je sais ici en français pour dire que le
combat contre l'antisémitisme et le
nôtre c'est celui de toute la nation
c'est un grand pas pour l'humanité
contre la barbarie et ses multiples
visages
l'antisémitisme est toujours
annonciateur de drame universel
l'histoire est là sous l'enseigné
et pourtant certains en tendance à
oublier ou à réviser l'histoire nous
devons mesurer aujourd'hui que la menace
qui pèse depuis tant d'années sur les
juifs de france s'étend à toute notre
société nos forces de l'ordre dans un
enseignant nos libertés et notre
république
soyons lucides nous devons aujourd'hui
lutter contre de nouvelles formes
d'antisémitisme favorisée par l'islamo
gauchisme la lutte contre cet
antisémitisme doit être une lutte sans
merci
car c'est un combat pour nos enfants
c'est un combat pour nos valeurs pour la
liberté c'est bel et bien un combat pour
la france
les juifs sont toujours les visites des
temps sombres et de nouveaux temps
sombres se profilent les juifs sont les
premières victimes
mais jamais les dernières retenons les
notions de l'histoire ne tardons pas ne
regardons pas ailleurs alors que le ciel
tourner à l'orage relever ensemble en
français en républicain selon fille qui
est lancé ce défi qui est lancé à tous
ceux que nous sommes tout ce à quoi nous
croyons nous devons à la mémoire de sara
lee me faisant de ce jour où nous
pensons d'abord à elle le premier jour
une nouvelle mobilisation calme lucide
implacable pour la justice pour la
liberté pour nos valeurs et pour la
défense de notre civilisation avant que
le passé la parole à d'autres aux
invités je voudrais remercier de leur
présence fraternelle
tous les élus qui sont là et ceux qui
vous monte et ce après voudrais
remercier monsieur dupont-aignan d'être
présent et je voudrais un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour votre un billet
mais habile qui depuis le premier jour
combat
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir la
président de la région ile de france
madame
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis si je suis là parmi vous
aujourd'hui c'est parce que le meurtre
de sarah et demi sans procès me
bouleverse et me révolte
il me bouleverse il vaut révolte mais
nous sommes tous ici tous ici par delà
tous les clivages politiques
tous ici les élus de la région ile de
france
venu témoigner venu témoigner que la
mémoire de sarah sexagénaire tabac s'est
défenestrée parce qu'elle était juive
nous lui rendrons justice oui justice
pour sarah halimi cette justice elle
était attendue elle est espéré à procès
aurait pu nous faire comprendre
il aurait pu soulager les blessures il
aurait pu aussi éclairer l'opinion sur
les effets de la haine antisémite
une aide qui est bien loin de cet angle
et qui fait aujourd'hui encore des
ravages parmi nous oui on l'a dit
l'église d'un nouvel antisémitisme en
france il ne vaut pas taire la réalité
il ne faut pas faire l'autruche il ne
faut pas regarder ailleurs
il faut que nous nous mobilisions tous
et je le dis là encore par de la limite
des différents partis parce que c'est
l'intérêt général parce que c'est la
république parce que c'est la france
alors oui un procès aurait obligé le
meurtrier a regardé ses victimes et la
société en face mais non il n'y aura pas
de procès
et pourtant c'est avéré le meurtrier de
sarah halimi était bien délinquants
antisémite il n'était pas fou il avait
choisi sa cible
mais voilà l'homme était sous l'emprise
de la drogue
en un mot il est bien coupable mais il
n'était pas responsable
alors vous le savez je respecte le
travail des psychiatres je respecte le
travail des juges qui applique la loi
mais cette loi elle est mal faite elle
est mal faite
elle est mal faite parce qu'elle nous
dit qu'un criminel peut être dispensé de
procès parce qu'il s'est volontairement
shooter alors vous allez me dire ça nous
surprend tous parce qu'on sait tous ici
qu'un chauffard ivre
c'est une circonstance aggravante on
sait tous qu'un conjoint livre qui tue
sa compagne c'est une circonstance
aggravante
ils ont brisé des vies et pourtant il
n'y aura pas de procès pour le meurtrier
de sarah halimi alors nous ne cherchons
pas la logique mais il faut très
rapidement clarifier le régime
d'irresponsabilité pénale défini par
l'article 122-1 du code pénal alors j'ai
entendu christophe castaner j'ai entendu
le ministre de la justice qui au moment
nous nous nous réunissons aujourd'hui
nous dit que
gloire va être portée au parlement alors
tant mieux
cette nouvelle loi c'est votre victoire
cette nouvelle loi c'est notre victoire
tous ici autre gagnant la victoire de la
nation française c'est la victoire du
peuple français au cours duquel la
justice est rendue
alors oui cette loi cette loi de justice
nous devrons la nommer la loi sarah
halimi parce qu'un si ça ne sera pas
mortes en vain car c'est ainsi nous
pourrons faire notre deuil en paix pour
que vive la république et vive la fosse
merci vraiment ce qui permet l on a
oublié citer quelqu'un qui est dans la
logique ans qui sont déplacés histoire
serge et béate klarsfeld fondateur de la
france est toujours là toujours présente
elle toujours la même endroit la
victoire
chanteuse exemple pour nous tous car
quand la halle ont indiqué une amie
quand tous ceux qui sont ici la fidélité
je voudrais vous dire à chacun d'entre
vous merci pour votre fidélité
je voudrais remercier la présence aussi
de patrick à 1 pour les chrétiens
d'orient et la gorge ou de montataire
madame la maire de paris madame hidalgo
des gens
aux amis
méfiez-vous n'est pas la hauteur de sa
la libye
la hauteur de sarah libye
finale anémique tous ceux qui ont été
tués ici pour être honorées
mary paris par l'ensemble des élus alors
soyez à la hauteur si l'on rentre place
n'est pas la relève sur la maire de
paris s'il vous plaît merci et je prends
l'engagement unique but ici devant vous
en tant que maire de paris et en
présence de tous ces élus de la
république qui sont venus ici soutenir
la mémoire de sa halimi je prends
l'engagement devant vous une rue où
sarah halimi verrait le jour à bari
cette rue ne rendra pas la vie à sa rage
mais lorsque nous nous promènerons leur
stonily saurons nous aurons son histoire
son visage son nom et nous savons que
cette histoire ce visage
ce nom est bien sûr celui d'une femme
assassinée parce que juive pour laquelle
nous demandons ici justice justice par
une nouvelle loi justice par une loi qui
s'appellera je l'espère la loi ça va
halimi
oui nous serons là nous serons là avec
elle et cette rue sarah halimi sera le
témoin de notre détermination à nous ici
peuple parisien peuple de france
à nous les élus de la république pour
dire que jamais jamais nous ne céderons
face à l'antisémitisme l'incité mutisme
c'est cette peste cette peste qui vient
qui vient affaiblir nos valeurs
républicaines affaiblir ce que nous
sommes ensemble et s'il ya quelque chose
que l'on apprend lorsqu'on est maire de
paris et lorsque l'on vise cette ville
lorsqu'on fille et respire l'histoire de
cette ville c'est que cette ville ne
serait pas ce qu'elle est sans l'apport
de la communauté juive
alors oui cette ville qui doit quant à
cette histoire qui est aujourd'hui la
nôtre dans cette ville ensemble nous
défendrons nos valeurs nos valeurs
républicaines et la mémoire de sarah
halimi tout comme la mémoire 2 mirek
nole tout comme la mémoire d'ilan halimi
nous ne céderons jamais nous serons là
contre vents et marées lorsqu'il fera de
l'orage et lorsqu'il fera aussi du
soleil mais nous serons là en permanence
debout debout pour la république est
aujourd'hui le visage de la république
c'est celui de sarah leamy je vous
remercie
chers amis je vous voyez là sur scène
c'est ça la république
c'est ça le peuple français qui vous
représente et dont ses avocats
on sait ben j sera qui ont refusé de
juger en pensant qu'ils étaient le
peuple français le peuple de france et
vous le coop de france 6e
merci on vous applaudir vous remercie
vous faire taire tous les cellules vous
êtes notre honneur à tout
je vous invite à des bons gros
cardiology
j'aimerais juste donner la parole
pendant quelques petites secondes à
quelqu'un qui a déclenché cette
opération à quelques années ses
meilleurs habits
bonsoir à tous je re de mouvoir là je
pense d'abord surtout ou skp de la shoah
qui sont là la vie fait qu' ils vont
dans quelques années partir il voit
encore des actes antisémites en france
nous ne pouvons pas rester sans procès
pour sarah halimi il faut impérativement
décision il n'y a pas eu trop c'est
après la perte à carbu copernic
il n'y a pas eu trop ces attentats y en
aura après 40 ans de la rue des rosiers
il n'y a pas eu procès et là aussi je
voulais avoir un beau gilles francs pour
le dj c'est là parce que parce que sa
maman croise tous les jours là ça ça
qu'il a massacré et qu'il a tué alors
elle le croise tous les jours pour lui
blanc ce n'est pas possible je veux
avoir confiance à la république
ce procès doit avoir lieu il doit avoir
lieu en france
mais s'il aura pas lieu il n'a pas lu en
france il aura lieu en israël
un choix et je ne peux pas quoi je suis
député de la république et je suis
législateur et nous avons vu la
jurisprudence
bienvenue ya eu des gens qui ont été
jugés qui ont été condamnés y compris
vacants lorsqu'il avait pris du cannabis
alors qu'on arrête alors qu'on arrête
j'aime mon pays j'aime la france j'ai
qu'un seul souhait comme vous tous tout
vous est ce soir je suis dans le suivre
c'est qu'il y ait un procès en france
pour ça va aller vite
merci de vous la donner la parole aux
combattants noémie madar des lieux
[Applaudissements]
au passif les deux solutions s'il vous
plaît pour noémie
merci gilles nous sommes si nombreux
partout en france
ici nous sommes des mairies nous sommes
des milliers contre l'antisémitisme nous
sommes des milliers pour sa halimi nous
sommes des milliers aujourd'hui à dire
non aux antisémites ce ne sont pas eux
qui gagneront le combat je ne sens pas
qui gagnera la lutte
les antisémites perdront il faut vite
au-delà de cette journée cette journée
n'est pas la fin d'un moment cette
journée et le début d'une époque le
début d'une mobilisation citoyenne le
début d'une mobilisation de tous les
citoyen français peu importe leur
religion peu importe leur origine et
nous étudiants c'est nous qui allons
faire la france d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
c'est nous qui est trop régénération est
temps qu'ils vont trop quand nous serons
ici
le combat continue pour que notre avenir
soit celui de la france soit élu la
république et soit celui de la lutte
contre la haine et ce ne sont pas elles
qui gagneront merci à vous et nous
sommes 6 2 pour donner
merci je voudrais vous passez pas passer
la parole à un ami le courage que vous
voyez sur tous les plateaux arides et
quatre filles de 30 aux républicains
chers amis
je suis venu vous dire deux choses
simples la première c'est que nous ne
devons pas accepter
jamais sous aucun prétexte cette idée
aussi absurde que dangereuse
selon laquelle l'émotion suscitée par un
acte antisémite
d'autres étaient entre la sphère de la
communauté juive
nous n'acceptons jamais la deuxième
chose que je voulais vous dire je viens
d'une famille musulmane je ne suis pas
juif je viens d'une famille musulmane
une de ces familles à l'image de
millions de familles françaises au sang
mêlé qui plongent leurs racines de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée tout en
ayant un amour passionnel pour la france
et c'est pour cette raison que je n'ai
pas besoin d'être juif pour être ému par
la tacc de l'école autres à tora de
toulouse
je n'ai pas besoin d'être suivi pour
claude et ilan halimi
je n'ai pas besoin d'être suis convaincu
manu la douleur des familles aux avatars
jared cohen trop von schell sada et
irritable je n'ai pas besoin d'être juif
pour comprendre et partager la douleur
des familles de mireille knoll et de
sarah a diminué parce que les nul besoin
d'être suisse pour sentir de l'empathie
de la fraternité vis-à-vis de ceux qui
sont frappés par un drame
pas besoin d'être juive pour être une
serre et par l'antisémitisme et enfin
pas besoin d'être juif pour se sentir
solidaire de ces familles qui ont quitté
des quartiers de banlieue par centaines
j'ai honte et scolariser leurs enfants
parce que certains élus irresponsables
ont pris prétexte de l'antisionisme pour
aller à coller quelques minables et
froid aux élections locales
en trottant ici dessus
je suis
au nom de
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande que recevoir comme il se
doit
monsieur bora de la table géopolitologue
c'est bon merci peuple de france je
passerai devant toi la vie et la mort
qui choisir la vie et tu vivras alors
c'est bien l'autre point commun tous
aujourd'hui les dents malheureusement
cette preuve d'une défaillance majeure
dans notre unité dans la 40e' de notre
unité car il a été estimé qu'une
personne parce que juive ne
bénéficierait pas de l'entièreté de ses
droits
ce n'est pas un accident depuis
maintenant 2002 je suis à vos côtés il
ya eu d'affaires de jc l'âme il ya eu la
ferme ericsson et hull affaire ilan
halimi
tout récemment un fumeur de joints parce
qu'il a jeté son chien par la fenêtre
après six mois de prison ferme et là
étrangement
oui mais ce malin vous avez envoyé un
message aux français qui consiste à dire
que un bon juif est un juif nord pire
mais ça je vous le pardonnerai jamais
c'est que par votre décision
sarah halimi est décédé une deuxième
fois alors en tant que français
musulmans j'ai proposé à m spizner
lorsqu'il déposera sa plainte en israël
a figuré parmi les témoins on est en
réussite et highline abb j'espère que le
sommet climat
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'était la condamnation de
l'homme mais aussi pour éclairer toutes
les haines les gens qui l'ont rejoint
aujourd'hui pour mieux comprendre les
rouages de cette justice qu'on a du mal
parfois à contrat pour le faire nous
avons demandé à béatrice brugère qui est
secrétaire général du syndicat unité
magistrat est faux de tonte et nous
expliquer l'inexplicable
béatrice rochelle
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup j'avance je suis influent
élu
la parole la tâche est difficile
en tout ce que j'ai entendu mais je suis
très honoré aussi d'être là je remercie
vivement les organisateurs de cette
invitation
on me donne l'occasion alors peut-être
pas d'expliquer l'inexplicable non je
dis tout de suite mais de m'exprimer sur
une affaire qui a convoqué évidemment
beaucoup de débats et de controverses à
et même jusqu'à l'intervention du
président de la république à la fois sur
le besoin d'un procès et dernièrement
sur cette annonce d'une modification de
la loi
alors je vous le dis tout de suite tout
de suite j'y suis tout à fait favorable
et je vais vous dire bonsoir aujourd'hui
je m'exprime au nom d'un syndicat qui
s'appelle unités magistrat il faut sont
que des magistrats que je représente la
classe et
je vais le pied de certaines questions
juridiques qui ont été suscitées par la
décision sur cette affaire à l'isthme
vous le comprendrez
il est impossible pour moi et c'est pas
le lieu pour moi non plus de critiquer
cette décision ni de refaire le procès
de cette affaire mais d'essayer d'en
comprendre les enjeux et je crois qu'il
a entendu tout à l'heure essayer de
faire que les choses soient un meilleur
pour l'avenir en donnant un éclairage à
la suite de l'émoi légitime que cette
décision a suscité et que je partage je
le dis tout de suite
les syndicats de magistrats n'est
affilié à aucun courant politique ni
religieux ni philosophique et de défense
aucune école de pensée ni de logique ni
corporatisme ma parole est libre comme
doit l'être la justice
pour nous la justice avait réuni à
droite ni à gauche ni même au centre
mais humaines compétentes
l'exemplaire et ne peut être qu'au
service de l'intérêt général qui doit
être qui doit être ma soeur notre salle
horizon
[Musique]
nous sommes conscients que dira le droit
n'est pas toujours rendre justice même
utile et deux équations dorée au maximum
de se rejoindre
à défaut de se confondre c'est pourquoi
nous sommes par nature réformiste
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas peur
de la critique si cette critique sert la
justice pour l'améliorer 116 la faire
évoluer et non pas la tragédie
ça ne sera pas la première fois
il faut que vous sachiez d'une décision
de justice provoquera de débats il sera
à l'origine de modification législative
ça a été le cas en 2008 sur une affaire
absolument épouvantable
j'étais la femme romain dupuy ce jeune
homme avait été déclaré irresponsable
souffrant d'une pathologie psychiatrique
à les prix du cannabis avait décapité
une infirmière
on avait une seconde et les experts
s'étaient aussi j'allais dire confronter
avec des visions différentes
la famille avait amendé après une
bataille d'experts
un procès en vain à l'époque l'état du
droit ne permettait aucune solution que
de déclarer
une irresponsabilité pénale de même la
dernière décision de justice récente met
en évidence des points de droit qu'il
convient sans aucun doute d'améliorer
j'en vois au moins trois la question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale
la mission des experts dans la
détermination de cette irresponsabilité
pénale
faut-il définir ce que c'est qu'un
trouble neuropsychique la question de la
prise de toxiques qui a déjà été évoqué
dans la commission d'une infraction dans
un contexte de banalisation de visage du
cannabis est une cause d'exonération
l'aggravation de diminution de
responsabilité et tout responsable
canton comme un fait faut-il de sa
propre consommation
lorsqu'on commet une infraction sachant
que la consommation de drogue est déjà
considéré comme une infraction
enfin et je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui vous tient à coeur la place de
l'audience comme et essence même de
l'acte de juger la loi 2010
à instaurer une audience mais une
audience devant la chambre d'instruction
qui a été déjà bien c'est est-ce que
c'est suffisant la prochaine loi devra
en revanche je suis persuadé à titre
personnel du rôle cathartique de
l'audience lieu par excellence du débat
du contradictoire nécessaires pour
rechercher la vérité et rendre la
justice
mais on réalité j'attire votre attention
toutes ces questions doivent être
évacués à l'aune de ce qu'on attend de
la justice dans notre société française
et dans notre république
en effet la justice n'est pas simplement
un objet de droit
c'est également un sujet de futures
hausses ans la philosophe hannah arendt
l'entendre c'est à dire qu'une oeuvre de
l'esprit de l'intelligence qui
nécessitent aussi cette volonté de
rechercher le vrai le bien et juste
nafi beaucoup de bière
merci pour vos tenues merci beaucoup
avait encore toute chaude les réveillera
préjuge après le juge
oui g12 auront pour clôturer cette
manifestation
jeanne atteint d'animer le fils de
farrah j'ai je vous laisse continuer
merci
en effet la justice a simplement à nous
alors c'est toute la différence entre
dire le droit
il faut bien s'en rendre compte et
rendent la justice et c'est pour ça que
les juges sont les gardiens des
promesses d'une société alors qu'elle
entendrait lorsque la constitution de 58
ans qui a été faite par le général de
gaulle présenter son nouveau projet il
rappelle que si les textes et les hommes
sont en parfait les institutions devient
ce qu'il faut les actions et des unités
la république notre vie par un triptyque
je voudrais rappeler situe la
souveraineté du peuple
l'appel de la liberté l'espérance de la
justice cette merveilleuse expression
l'espérance de la justice doit être le
coeur battant de notre république
cette espérance ne la portent tous et ce
sans doute la présence aussi de toutes
les personnes ici tous leurs acquis
la république comme disait camus le
courage ça s'organise la justice aussi
s'organise
c'est la raison pour laquelle si la loi
ne leur met un carton mais est ce une
boussole
il y a des pistes sérieuses dames et
lauriane d'amélioration dans le projet
qui sera proposé prochainement à
l'assemblée législative
vous pouvez compter sur nous des
magistrats car il ne faut pas croire ici
que les magistrats n'ont pas à coeur de
rendre cette justice pour exprimer
également quitté difficultés qu'ils
peuvent rencontrer ici il faut clarifier
le droit pour par exemple savoir si
canton de la drogue
c'est une circonstance atténuante c'est
une circonstance aggravante où c'est une
circonstance qui vous exonère de
responsabilité
ça sera un sujet qu'il faudra très
hachée aujourd'hui de façon défi
pour qui une jurisprudence cohérente et
qu'on n'est pas comme ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure des décisions qui soient
différentes et qui laisse penser que la
justice n'est pas juste dans la manière
de vendre
il y aura d'autres évidemment question
qui vont se poser le rôle des experts la
manière dont les juges s'appuient sur
ces experts et cela je crois c'est que
par exemple s'il deux experts ne sont
pas d'accord comme ça a été le cas sur
le dossier mais il faut systématiquement
privilégié le renvoi devant une
juridiction devant un tribunal qui le
lieu du débat qui est le lieu du
contradictoire qui est le dieu de la
recherche de la vérité et qui le font ce
même que je suis aimerait évidemment
cette proposition entouré côté des
cassures acquis leur montrer dans les
magistrats ils sont nombreux à vouloir
que les choses changent merci beaucoup
trop de vertiges et weezer je voudrais
pour conclure
taquet s'il vous plaît il a fait le
déplacement ce matin il s'est peu
exprimé sur la sphère jeu l'atalaye tout
ça nous cher ami je suis très ému
aujourd'hui de me retrouver parmi vous
tout d'abord j'aimerais remercier
personnellement chacun d'entre vous vous
vous être réalisés ici à paris mais
aussi partout dans le monde et avons
fait l'effort de se déplacer
je voudrais remercier les personnes qui
se sont réunies aussi à paris mais aussi
à marseille à nice à lyon à nantes
arrive à ville à strasbourg à bordeaux à
toulouse à montpellier
à lancy à cannes et à deauville posters
yaro en corse à ajaccio en amérique à
new york à los angeles
mangani à san francisco au canada à
toronto en hollande à la haye en
belgique à bruxelles
on y sert à tel-aviv jérusalem est
l'acte
je m'excuse si j'ai oublié encore
d'autres endroits voudrais remercier
aussi ceux qui ont exprimé leur volonté
de participer et qui n'ont pas pu nous
rejoindre je sais qu'ils sont de tout
coeur avec nous je voulais aussi
remercier personnellement monsieur
jonathan bea qui m'a donné beaucoup de
courage et de force pour venir et grâce
à qui je suis aujourd'hui parmi vous
chers amis
suite à la décision de la cour de
cassation qui rend irresponsable
l'assassin de ma mère nous ne pouvons
plus garder notre silence
même si on ne sort ni juriste et avocat
me psychiatre nous pouvons et même nous
devons exprimer notre incompréhension et
de son indignation face à cela il faut
que l'on m'explique
excusez moi que l'on nous explique
pourquoi
dans cette affaire on se focalise
seulement sur l'état mental de
l'assassin
[Applaudissements]
comment comprendre qu'aucune
investigation de son téléphone n'était
fait
comment comprendre que son compte
facebook n'est pas été investiguées et
qui a été entièrement effacé
pourquoi la reconstitution des fêtes
nous at elle été refusée des amis on
doit comprendre aussi pourquoi on le
présente comme un fou alors qu'il n'a
aucun antécédent psychiatrique et que
depuis l'assassinât lauzon un traitement
comment expliquer qu'il a passée qu'il a
un passé lourd était fiché à la police
qui a eu des séjours en prison et jamais
on ne la considérait comme un fou les
chers amis une des grandes incohérences
de ce dossier et que comme et que
comment quelqu'un qui a commis un acte
illégal de consommer du cannabis
la consommation de cannabis étant
illégale comment peut- être considérée
irresponsable et c'est vraiment un cas
une abolition du discernement
comment peut-il avoir la faculté de
regret son cri
comment pouvait-il avant la faculté de
citer des soies de djihadistes
lorsque sur un board expertise l'expert
avons devant 500 personnes à la cour
d'appel s'être trompé dans son abord
pourquoi pourquoi ça n'a pas été retenu
mesdames messieurs mes chers amis je
sais qu'une partie de toutes nos
questions
notre sentiment est que depuis le début
on nous casse la vérité tant qu'il n'y
aura pas de lumière dans cette affaire
il y aura toujours une tâche dans
l'histoire de la france une atteinte aux
valeurs morales de notre république
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous sous
l'effet de la connaît mais nous devons
la contenu et nous devons prendre
conscience des conséquences de cette
impunité
et surtout du danger qu'elles
représentent
il ne suffit pas de corriger la loi
mais il faut juger le criminel est aussi
le punit les amis ce serait un échec
pour nous sa famille ce sera un échec
pour toute la france
de devoir faire appel à la cour
européenne ou encore de devoir faire
appel à la justice d'un pays étranger
mes chers amis
la justice doit être fait en france
si il y en a qui se font passer il faut
prendre pour des irresponsables nous la
france doit prendre ses responsabilités
mes chers amis
j'aimerais vous parler de quelque chose
même si pour moi cela est très difficile
vous inquiétez pas je vais vous épargner
je veux pas vous raconter les atrocités
qu'il a subies lors de son assassinat
vous voyez
on parle beaucoup de la terre de sava
limites mais moi j'aimerais vous parler
des panthères madame halimi qu'ils
étaient des valeurs qu'elle véhicule et
qui nous hante 38 alou ses enfants et
petits enfants
tout d'abord ma mère était médecin et
ensuite directrice de crèche dans le 4e
arrondissement de paris c'est dévié pour
les enfants comme pour les parents
elle était très appréciée même de son
personnel de crèche saccages dans le
quatrième était connu c'était la crèche
de madame halimi tout celui qui avait
réussi à obtenir une place dans cette
crèche santé méritants à nous aussi ses
enfants elle nous a inculqué non respect
de l'autre en tant que médecin elle
était toujours prête à venir aider à
toute personne dans le besoin
c'était une femme courageuse qui n'avait
pas peur d'affronter les difficultés de
vie elle nous a toujours inculqué à
prendre nos responsabilités et de les
assumer
s'il y avait bien un trait de caractère
qui déplaisait à ma mère c'était celui
de l'indifférence
elle même
ne pouvait jamais rester indifférente à
la souffrance d'autrui beaucoup de
parents la crèche et les personnes qui
l'ont côtoyé pourront témoigner comment
elles s'avèrent donné le courage aux
plus découragés de l'espoir en plus
désespérées et des conseils aux plus
désemparés les problèmes que les autres
lui confier devenaient les siens et elle
l'avait de répit tant qu'elle n'avait
pas envisager toutes les solutions qui
pourraient les sous le sud faisant
croire ma mère n'était pas une vieille
dame de détails mais quand même elle
avait que 60 euros elle était jeune
d'esprit
elle est tellement plein d'enthousiasmé
jours pour de nouvelles initiatives des
randonnées des sorties et autres
elle était très vivante elle était très
bon j'ai ses petits enfants et aimait
partager avec eux de bons moments chers
amis je pourrais parler encore
longuement sur elle et c'est une mission
difficile de devoir se limiter à
quelques phrases et je ne veux pas vous
retenir plus que ça je m'adresse à vous
à vous tous citoyens et citoyennes
français à qui les valeurs morales de la
république lui sont chers de se soucier
de l'avenir dans notre public de se
soucier à l'avenir de nos enfants et
d'une autre de leur éducation mais aussi
ceux ci on nous de nos parents soyons
attentifs à leurs besoins et à leur
sécurité
unissons nous pour cette cause grâce à
dieu
aujourd'hui nous trouvons cette union si
on se bat et on agit tout le bien autour
de soi
avec l'aide de dieu d'autres monde sera
meilleur
[Musique]
pour signer je suis sûr que de là où
elle est lp est fier de nous tous qui
dans la mobilisation pour que justice
lui soit rendue avons fait preuve de
tout sauf d'un différence au sens qui a
été le sien
l'occasion nous est donnée d'ailleurs la
douche sa famille d'exprimer toute notre
reconnaissance envers tout ce qui de
partout dans le monde se sont mobilisés
pour notre cause aujourd'hui encore
quatre ans après son assassinat
votre soutien nous est très cher
je vous remercie à tous ils sont avides
nous avons j'ai peur qu'ils
[Applaudissements]
applaudissent et très fort jésus à
travers vos applaudissements à travers
votre coeur et votre amour
il a trouvé la force de trouver les mots
les mots justes les mots comme le disait
jonathan et quelques minutes les bons
qui sont sortis du coeur et qui sont
allés droit au coeur merci je tiens
d'abord à remercier will i am et
johnatan pour leur confiance ils nous
ont fait andy démêlés avec eux ce combat
qui est celui de tout un pays
je tiens aussi à travailler a remercié
ces gens avec qui on a travaillé dit et
jour pour créer ce rassemblement pour
qu'il soit ce qui l'a été aujourd'hui
gelée là mais je vais sûrement oublié je
voulais remercier
jolie gueule surya cohen gil taïeb 30
avions des gens qui sont dans l'ombre
jean-luc les dernières musiques ans et
tous les autres sont nombreux plus de 50
personnes
cyril également plus que 50 personnes
ont travaillé de 8 les jours avec une
seule motivation totalement
désintéressée la seule motivation qui
l'habite et que justice soit faite
c'est que nous fassions aujourd'hui
rayonner la lumière que nous apportions
de la lumière face à l'obscurantisme
je tiens à remercier les forces de
police il faut protéger tout au long de
cet événement et je tiens à remercier
toutes les communautés qui se sont
réunis aujourd'hui nous retrouverons ce
tissu qui l'atroce nous avons des
drapeaux kani et des drapeaux
australiens côte à côte et des drapeaux
français
c 'est la société procès c'est ça que
nous devons revenir au score aujourd'hui
est le début d'un nouveau mouvement et
vous êtes les ambassadeurs vous êtes les
ambassadeurs de la france tout ça sonne
charles michel de monde
astuce de nogent exhalons ensemble en
tablier la marseillaise
[Musique]
et
à
ouais
j'ai on
[Applaudissements]
qu'il y ait
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean
[Musique]
non
merci a tous les atouts pour verser
beaucoup votre engagement votre courage
le combat ne fait que commencer
merci
restez vigilants et rend très bien et
que je vous protège
ma vie à ce point
ban
[Musique]
m
moi je
[Musique]
je suis
donc on
la patrouille
je
[Musique]